i'm going to open the public hearing on
house bill
1338 an act establishing a committee to
study imposing attacks on manufacturers
based on the cost of
to dispose of single-use products and
product packaging materials
the prime sponsor is representative reed
representative reed you want to
thank you so much mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee for
welcoming me this is my first time ever
in my three terms to be before ways and
means i think it took me three terms to
work up the courage to put in anything
that would come before you
um and this is still just a study
committee so
nothing uh
still nothing too ambitious uh for the
record my name is ellen reed i represent
rockingham 17 new market and new fields
and um i want to start by actually i
want to start by saying the chair of the
committee that i clerk representative
lang
is not here and i've already ripped him
good for for showing up late and missing
he is coming yes he is coming um but i
want to start um with kind of a
hypothetical situation
can you imagine
if
maybe in the days of the industrial
revolution and the factories started and
we had allowed them without any
restraint to continue dumping all the
toxic waste that they could create into
our rivers and streams unmitigated no
restrictions and instead of putting
restrictions on them what we did is we
demanded that every municipality create
a giant public spending program
at the taxpayers expense in order to go
and filter that waste out of the streams
and rivers that these companies were
polluting
can you imagine that giant massive
public spending program at the cost of
the taxpayers that we were allowing to
exist instead of simply requiring that
those manufacturers those companies
either
not pollute those rivers or pay to clean
up those rivers
it would be an affront i think to
everyone of any political leaning that
we would do that to taxpayers
and
the sad situation is that is exactly
what we've allowed to happen with solid
waste
essentially we've allowed companies with
no incentive on
reducing their packaging or reducing
their single use items or
making those items out of uh easier to
recycle or easier to dispose of
materials
we've given them no incentive to to be
conscientious about that
because we since the beginning have had
towns operate these solid waste
management programs at the expense of
so this the situation we have is
actually a well understood phenomenon in
economics it's called externalization
so our capitalist system is supposed to
work in that
you as a manufacturer or producer of a
product incorporate all the costs
associated with creating your product
into
the actual cost of the product and once
you take all those costs into effect you
sell that item at a profit and you work
in the competitive market in order to to
bring your costs down but we are not
doing that because they're allowed to
externalize the cost of these things
that they produce the disposal of these
so what happens is because they have no
incentive to reduce their cost reduce
their packaging make it out of easier to
dispose of materials they very
frequently will create products that
and this has been a well understood
phenomenon especially in food that have
bigger packaging but the same amount of
food in the packaging to make the
consumer think they're buying a bigger
product that's been over the last 15
years or so that that's been
a trend
and they also will make it fancier make
the package feel heavier all at the cost
again of taxpayers who have to
foot the bill for disposing of these
products
and as we know
whereas
recycling programs used to be relatively
easy still at a cost to the towns
because of the situation with china
towns in many many towns have had to
reduce their recycling programs much of
the waste ends up in landfills even
though the people of the town actually
think that they're recycling those
materials
so this externalization of costs at the
expense of the taxpayer
is bad it is essentially theft they're
saying this is a cost we have associated
with creating a product but we're not
actually paying for that cost we're
letting someone else foot the bill
um
and
if we could and make them internalize
those costs as they should then tax
rates for taxpayers will go down
especially in the form of property tax
which as we all know is uh very harsh in
this state because most of the mean the
solid waste is conducted on the
municipal level
so this idea
is that and it's
it's it's my idea that i've been kicking
around for five or six years
is that we simply tax manufacturers of
those goods single-use products or
a disposable packaging that we tax them
at a rate commensurate with how much it
costs for us to dispose of it
so if they're creating something that is
in a compostable or biodegradable
package or single-use product that would
be a very small amount if any if they're
doing something that's like a really
impossible or difficult to recycle
material or toxic material which many of
these materials are like styrofoam or
what have you
then we would tax them more and the idea
is that that money would then be
distributed to the entities mostly
municipalities that are actually having
to do the disposing and cover those
costs
i obviously know
that
this is uh well first of all that we
don't have the market share in the
country to kind of impact the
manufacturers and put incentive on them
in this way so i've proposed that the
study include the idea of an interstate
uh
an interstate uh
what's the word
compact yes thank you i couldn't buy i
couldn't reach for the word an
interstate compact um so that if a
certain amount of certain percentage of
the population of the country were to
sign on then it would go into effect
um
also
the
hold on if you think about i imagine and
this is just speculation because this is
just a study and i'm just i don't have
the expertise to put an actual
full-fledged bill before you but i'm
asking for for us to study this new idea
that most likely the tax would be mere
pennies on a product
if you think about the actual cost of
actually disposing of for example a
so
anyway uh
i guess that's basically everything i
have here to cover
the it's a new idea
i think it's has a lot of potential i
know new ideas are scary but we haven't
studied it before i know a lot of people
have reticence in doing another study
committee but this is one that hasn't
been done so i ask that you understand
that this is worth a look and and uh
vote to have a study committee on this
and i'll happily take questions
thank you for your testimony
representative reed
thank you mr chair uh
thank you representative
for taking my question
so you're talking about an interstate
compact do you know of any other states
that have a similar bill before them
that or we want to be the tip of the
sword here
on this issue i think on an inter yes i
don't know of any states that have this
particular idea like i said this came
out of my own noggin
but
i think for an interstate compact it's
pretty safe to be the tip of the sword
right because she doesn't go into effect
until other states do sign on so
it's okay to be the tip of the sword in
that case
uh representative elmi followed by
representatives
thank you mr chairman
representative reed
is there on i'm sorry actually that this
bill
was titled with the word tax in it yeah
me too i'm not sure
there is a large amount of study on
landfills going on in
environment and agriculture
and would you
do you think that there is enough
information about what is easily
recyclable and what isn't
that um this wouldn't have to be covered
first
i might add i'm
i'm from lebanon city of lebanon the
landfill manager there is the most
uh
creative
maybe in quite a few states
in the country and on has been teaching
us about what
can be recycled by him which is totally
different than what can be recycled by
casella et cetera et cetera and um
and i don't know if there's any kind of
that they
the landfill operators around the
country have have put together enough
information about in general i mean you
can point out to styrofoam but the fact
that black plastic is less recyclable
than clear plastic
in most places but not all
uh
makes could make this difficult if that
hasn't been ironed out yet
are you
what do you know about that thank you
i'm so glad you brought this up because
it is a point that i was struggling to
remember as i was going through but i
intended to talk about it so um so
the understanding the physical science
the material science of the actual
materials is well understood what it
takes to recycle this type of material
versus that type of material which is
why very clearly put into the study
committee taxing different uh
materials at different rates based on
the ease of proper disposal so you're
absolutely right not all recycle we talk
about recyclables if it's a toggle
switch they are not created equal some
materials are technically recyclable but
the product you get at the end is
poor quality and it costs a lot of
money and effort and time to actually go
through that process so it's not really
worth it
so the point is there's no incentive
right now in a manufacturer to prefer
one to another because they don't they
don't really care once it's out of their
store
they're done with it
but the taxpayer is left with the burden
so yes we do understand the physical
science very very very well in terms of
what what actually the landfills are
having to deal with that's something
that a study committee like this
could
survey and find out in the municipal
landfills
about what percentage of the waste you
deal with is this type versus that type
and what do you think it would cost
follow-up
i'll follow up
on
that being the case the technology of it
would you be
inclined to allow
if we could figure out how to merge this
into a study committee
over at ena
if they are so inclined would that be
okay that would be probably preferable
as a matter of fact
again we understand the technology
that's needed the problem is is that
it's up to the taxpayer to afford the
technology to do all these different
kinds of recycling right now if we end
up taxing manufacturers based on how
much they are putting a burden on
taxpayers right now we tax them at that
rate then we can
we can get the funds to properly dispose
of everything that they create and i
want to be clear this is limited in my
study committee outline to single use
and and packaging right so it's not like
clothing or other you know furniture
stuff like that
but yes i i would be happy for this to
be merged so that we can get as much
information from the towns and from the
industries that deal with recycling as
possible
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
this is going to apply to manufacturers
how do you do you anticipate it also
applying to foreign manufacturers and if
so how would we actually tax them
again it's a study committee because i i
freely admit i don't have the economic
or mathematical or technical engineering
expertise to know all the details that
should go into such a complex idea but
it's a new idea and i think a study
committee could find out that kind of
information and land on whatever the
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative reed for presenting to us
today um in your in in your statements
earlier you talked about uh the cost of
goods what it takes to prepare the cost
of goods from a manufacturing point of
view and how that is passed down in the
price to the consumer
what is the difference in the consumer
paying
taxation on their end to take care of
this type of a service and that tax or
fee being
included in the price of the good that
is passed down to the to the consumer
well a tax is involuntary right like you
don't get to to choose whether or not
but you can choose whether or not to buy
it uh buy a product on a shelf based on
the cost so it's this doesn't the idea
the study is a study but if the idea
ever were to come to fruition
it wouldn't prevent any manufacturer
from creating a giant styrofoam
disgusting package or whatever but then
that cost would be reflected in the cost
of the item and that consumer can decide
whether or not that's worth it to them
which is the choice that they don't have
now
uh mr follow thank you thank you mr
chairman uh i'm i i didn't quite
understand your i don't know if you
understood my question
the price if if this if this tax or fee
is imposed on the manufacturer they
would probably
wrap that into the cost of the good
right right
so what you're saying is if that isn't
wrapped in to the cost of the good and
the good is too much then the consumer
would decide not to buy them correct and
that also provides an incentive to the
manufacturer to not do those exact kinds
of things right but yes it doesn't
prohibit that and so the consumer can
make the choice whether or not they want
to pay that extra bit of money for the
extra sized box that can't be recycled
yada yada whereas right now those things
are being bought
with no
kind of consideration for that price and
yet all of the taxpayers equally have to
fund the disposal of those items thank
you representative
for other questions
representative romney
so i'm listening to you looking at my
pen
so
so many manufacturers depend to me this
is a disposable pen
right so
basically in your definition
when this pen is disposed of
because this disposable pen the pen
company
paper mate
would have to
have this tax imposed on them
but when i get when i buy the package of
pens it's in a paper carton
i'll tell you paper papermate isn't
manufacturing the paper carton they have
another manufacturer that does that and
i have uh buy like 10 pens at a time in
a package
so that
that
company would have to be taxed and and
in this case is just using a simple
example
so
these these guys may be based in ohio
the package company may be based
somewhere else could be based overseas
i i know this is i know you want to
study but this just begs the question
about
how practical this would be
because there's so many companies that
this would impact i mean
how do you keep track of that i mean how
do you
how do you tax that i i don't know and
are we talking about
it's like three questions so far in
okay so first of all i personally don't
consider the pen uh single use but the
the point remains you can point to any
number of things that are single use
your example is valid um your question
is they the the manufacturers who
produce the end product that gets sold
to the consumer they use a number of
people and sources of of different
materials and whatever
my point is that they end up they're the
end
manufacturer that produces the item that
goes to the consumer so they pay that
tax if they don't want to use if they
don't want to pay as much of a tax they
use another source or another type of
material so that will end you don't end
up directly taxing those manufacturers
of the original items because they're
not creating the consumer end product
but what you end up having is a market
incentive for them to go through other
manufactures or other sources of those
materials that are more easily disposed
disposed of or more cheaply disposed of
properly so that's that's my thought but
again as you pointed out this is
a study and so this is the kind of
question that could be discussed
but i don't see it as overly complicated
or difficult to you know to an
unworkable idea because you're not
taxing all of these manufacturers of all
these different materials that are
selling to manufacturers you're taxing
the end
product which then has an impact on the
so when
your vision of this because you talk
about tax and i heard the conversation
that maybe
shouldn't be a tax bill but it sounds
like it is
uh
i mean are we talking about business
taxes businessing up taxes is that what
you're envisioning i mean
technically this is a tax on
manufacturers so this would be a kind of
business tax very specific to what they
are creating so if they don't want to
pay that tax and yes that does get
passed on to the consumer as
representative nunes pointed out and i
pointed out the value of that but if
they want to pay that tax and they don't
want their product to be more expensive
then all they have to do is use
more recyclable materials
more
compostable materials biodegradable
materials less packaging in general
smaller packaging
that's all they have to do so i
anticipate that that's what they will do
rather than pay more tax
and in fact the way i had it listed is
that if they use those good types of
materials they wouldn't pay any tax now
having said that this is a tax reduction
bill because what this does is reduces
people's property tax that they're
currently paying to dispose of some
thank you mr chairman uh representative
reed
would this uh when we tax cigarettes we
don't tax
altria
we don't tax white
uh philip morris yeah we tax the uh
distributor in new hampshire
to the retailers
on
it seems to me that that this we'd have
to do something like that sure
that the just like uh representative
abrami's example is well are we taxing
the original manufacturer of the
materials themselves you if you tax the
distributor then if in essence what
you're doing is putting that market
pressure on the manufacturers so it's
the same the same proc process in
principle
thank you
representative reed had you considered
how
you're going to determine
the
amount of the tax and that's going to
vary from manufacturer to manufacturer
it i don't see it varying from
manufacturer manufacturer because this
is based on the actual disposal the cost
of properly disposing a particular
material per pound or per ounce or
whatever per ton
that doesn't change between manufacturer
manufacturer
the how that gets applied to the
manufacturer does because they make the
decision whether or not they create
something that's really difficult to
attack or to dispose of or they create
something that's like all biodegradable
and composable they they determine how
much they get taxed by that but the
actual rate would stay the same per the
for the material
so if the material was styrofoam would
be one one right and if it was cardboard
or another type of material would be
another rate that's the idea but again
this is a study committee and it's a new
idea so it needs study
but it's a powerful idea it has lots of
potential
well i personally wouldn't be keeping
track of it
but what i'm not sure what you mean
about keeping track in terms of
the state i imagine department of
revenue which is right behind me would
have to um keep track of some of that
and then there would be
distribution to the towns right based on
the number of pounds so this does have
an administrative cost associated which
because of the situation
we can incorporate into that tax because
that administrative cost is part of the
have you come up with any suggestions on
who makes the decision on the
distribution
but
so no because this is a study committee
and i trust that the committee knows
better than me any study committee who
has experience would know better than me
about how that should properly be
administered
thank you
further questions representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
following up on what
um representative
had just said regarding the
administrative costs in which you said
that uh
dra behind you would
follow up how
i i just can't get beyond you're talking
about a fractional cost for styrofoam a
fractional cost for
the uh plastic that the
pen
comes wrapped in
a fractional cost for the uh the hanger
how about
how how can you figure that out without
increasing the cost of the pin from 99
cents to
i i think that's a bit of hyperbole if
you don't mind me saying 99 cents to 99
it doesn't cost a hundred dollars to
dispose of a single pin um but
in the question about administration is
um is a valid one but i presume that
this would be mostly done from by
reporting from the manufacturers
themselves
we have sold x number of units
each unit contains x number of ounces of
styrofoam x number of ounces of
cardboard x number of ounces of whatever
so that is easy math multiplication they
sold this many units in new hampshire
times the number of pounds of each type
of material in that unit they can report
and it's simple math from there
okay so what you're saying
it's a tax after the fact
yes
sure i mean again this is a study
committee but if they find out a better
way to do that then that's fine but yes
you can so it wouldn't necessarily at
the end result then obviously any
increased cost
will be passed on to the consumer but
it's not a per unit tax necessarily
unless the powers that be decided that's
easier to do
but you can simply ask for the reporting
for the previous year and then send them
any further questions representative
thank you mr chairman
the dra is not
trained in chemistry
on
wouldn't it be important to get the
department of environmental services
involved in this
the people that are in their uh
their landfill sure i brought up the dra
strictly as the administrative or part
and important part of the administrative
section of this in terms of you know
putting out the the numbers uh
to the you know to the manufacturers and
how much they're going to owe in taxes
and then distributing that to the towns
but that's just the administrative
section how each of those rates is
determined would be up to experts i mean
this is very common for departments to
have communication perhaps they should
have better communication at times but
it's very common for that information to
pass back and forth and to your previous
point um just like we would be combining
two study committees from two different
committees
yes we would have communication between
the experts and the people doing the
administration
know before representative
romney asked you another question
is
why is it that you limit a study
committee to
four members of the house two from each
party
and one member of the senate
um so
two
two reasons um i know in years past that
there were always two members of the
senate in order to have complete
bipartisanship i wanted equal numbers
from the house from both parties and i
can say that since i'm an independent um
and i uh the senate even though in years
past there was always two members per
committee they would always amend these
study committees to only have one member
of the senate because senators typically
feel very overworked so since we know
that's what they're going to do most
likely just have one have equal numbers
in the house and then you have an odd
number of committee members
okay the reason i ask that question is
because
in your testimony you refer to the dra
and i would imagine
also the environmentals
why won't you have
them as
tired that's more of a study commission
from what i understand um rather than a
committee but
i'm happy very very happy to do that as
it stands now it's legislative and they
solicit the information from the dra
environmental services anybody else the
town
waste disposal entities they they can
solicit that but if this committee
prefers it to be a formal study
commission where you have all of those
members actively is part of the
commission and i'm happy for that too my
understanding is that's harder to do
than a study committee
representative
one more
i'll make it a
would you agree with me
given the national scope of what you're
trying to do here
uh wouldn't it be better that you take
this idea to
to your
our federal congress people senator you
know house members and senators
and
see if there's merit
for them to study it
versus new hampshire studying this would
you believe that i think that the
federal government is rather
dysfunctional
and would you believe further that i
uh i have seen many many movements
across the country that have started
with state laws and then ended up
becoming federal law because federal law
thank you for your testimony thank you
does that anybody else wish to testify
dave gervais
will you
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee um
i i normally don't get overly agitated
over study committee bills and so i had
not intended to testify on this
but i thought it was important to
because ultimately
you folks are going to be voting on this
bill and i thought at least one member
of the public ought to be participating
in the hearing to
just a couple of thoughts coming from
the from the previous testimony part of
what makes this
idea problematic
is it is solely focused on new hampshire
manufacturers and which leaves us with a
couple of questions
how would the manufacturer be taxed if
they're producing a single use product
but exporting it to other states or
other countries so it's not affecting
landfills in new
hampshire how would what we refer to as
foreign manufacturers meaning they're in
another state or another country but
importing goods into new hampshire be
taxed i don't think the state has the
ability
to tax them although i suppose
you could prohibit them from importing
product into the state if you chose to
another concern is why are we focusing
just on manufacturers
the
items in question go don't go directly
from the manufacturer to the consumer
manufacturers in general sell their
product in bulk to distributors
distributors sell that product to
retailers retailers sell it to consumers
why aren't we extracting some form of
tax along the whole
supply chain as it gets to consumers
including consumers because they're the
ones who are purchasing the product
um
reps of all me made it an interesting
observation and and i'm happy to say uh
representative almi that i agree with
you completely
on this it's unfortunate this bill was
uh used tax in the title because it
ended up in this committee and and
with all due respect and i work with
this committee closely i don't think
you're the appropriate committee to be
discussing
whether a study of of single-use waste
is is a good idea or a bad idea i
thought representative almi had a
terrific suggestion i don't know how one
goes about it but i'm sure there's a way
to suggest to legislators who are
working with environment and agriculture
on solid waste
studies
looking at the solid waste issue in the
state which we all recognize as a
significant issue to also consider
ideas such as this is a part of the
study that they already have in place so
mr chair thank you for the opportunity
to testify i will fill out a pink card i
just wanted to provide the committee
with some opposing thoughts as you look
toward executing the bill
thank you for your testimony mr gervais
questions representative
dave du
prone to the idea of going after the
distributors of the products inside of
new hampshire what
problems do you see with that
if any
aside from the general idea which you
may not like
for me it starts with the general idea
which i think is problematic but there's
all kinds of other problems that that
have already been um
identified by by your colleagues on the
committee which is how do you track this
who is responsible for the information
who's responsible for the enforcement
how is this
woven into an audit of the company
there's
and
and then again you know
if it's limited to manufacturers and
distributors should it also be uh
include
retailers and should it also include
consumers the ones who are purchasing
thank you
further questions
representative romney
thanks mr chair thanks for taking my
are you aware of any any
study committees or commissions out
there that are looking at solid waste
right now well that's that's an
excellent question and and i have to
answer um
as you know because we've worked closely
together for a number of years that's
not an area within bia that i focus on i
have my colleagues that do
but i'm sure just in scanning the bills
i have seen things related to
solid waste and i wish i could be more
concrete but but it's just not my area
of expertise so i'm unsure about the
legislation that may be going on
well
let me just uh
question for the chair thank you dave
question for the chair yes can we have
our researcher research that to see if
there are any active it sounds like
representative lang may have mr chairman
i just scan the uh ena
their their build list
while they have only ones they have one
study commission relative to
site planning for landfills but that's
it and then they also have a bottle bill
for a disposable type of product that is
all that's over there right now so i
don't see any bills that this would
cleanly attach to at all
i'm not talking about
miss chair i'm not talking about bills
i'm talking about existing commissions
or study committees that are out there
already
because we have plenty of them that are
turning away on different topics
again they just closed one that was they
repealed one last year that was in that
it finished its work and closed it okay
but okay that's just for discussion
representative schamberg
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
duvet for taking my question
uh
wouldn't it be better for a new
hampshire study commission instead of
just disregarding
out of hand
i take it the knot of the head is yes
i didn't realize that was a question
could you
wouldn't it be better
for a study commission instead of
you're asking do i think we should do
the study committee rather than just
saying it's a bad
idea i didn't see a bad idea
well i guess
yeah i didn't mean to put words into
your mouth
um
i think it's probably an an unworkable
idea but
you're right
it
maybe deserves a closer look but i'm
suggesting rather than
having it as a study committee that is
focused so narrowly on establishing
attacks on single-use products that it
be woven into a broader
review of issues relating to landfills
in the state and to representative
abrami's question
i suggest because there's a whole
department within environmental services
that deals with this issue it would be
worth
talking to the commissioner
saying we've had this issue identified
in legislation
what do you think might be the best
approach to
to either getting an answer to this or
having it become a part of a larger
review
representative
well this was just
like a previous one a comment today i
think it was yesterday the ena
did an entire day of landfill work
and
the legislature and the ena committee
seem to be quite interested in
doing something about our landfill
problem which is becoming quite critical
at this point
so i think that
that they would you ought to talk to the
chair of ena as well
thank you
any further questions
sir none thank thank you mr sharon i
will fill out the pink card
anybody else wish to testify for or
against house bill 1338
jen is there any
okay
then
nobody else
testifying far against the bill and
closing the public hearing on house bill
1338.
the message here
mr chair
yes
um
the
question came up before about people who
are watching this
remotely and there's a mechanism for
their signing
yes their support i don't support and we
were going to come back to that i don't
know how we're going to get back to it
because i think we learned that it's not
until the end of the day that you know
how many people have signed up
so
yes
there was a email that came out
describing a procedure for testifying
for or against
and it refers you to the general court
website
it would tell you what length
to
click on and then you can
sign in and support or not
maybe maybe when we have our work
sessions
we could have a report with respect to
maybe when we have the work sessions on
each bill which may lead to executive
sessions
a piece of
the introduction of each bill would be
and these are the numbers
for that bill
where we're seeing news reports about
bills and they often have numbers of
people
who signed in pro and con it's part of
the picture so we need to be sure we
have that
picture
right we're having a work session on all
of our bills
how we get access to that oh yeah
uh right guys
hold on just a minute
we're gonna have a work session
uh next week wednesday on all of our
bills
and then
what i plan to do
is to go over all
those
notices that have came in over the
internet for or against
jennifer
would you
yep
so if you visit
the main page of the general court
and you scroll down to links to meeting
schedules
under house you'll see house online
testimony submissions
you can click there and enter
or select
the house ways and means committee
and select
the bill number
and you'll see the online
submissions there
um it will list the names whether they
support or oppose
and if they've uploaded
a pdf
testimony that will also appear online
so
you all can see that the public can see
that and it totals the support and
opposition so i just pulled up 1338
and online we have eight in support and
two opposed
so that's something everyone can access
now
and then when we do the work session
next week
we'll update the information
anything
you'd be satisfied with just the number
of yes four and number against is that
correct
i would be i think it would be helpful
to all of us if we could have
an email that tells us exactly how to
access that information what jennifer
just
jen
one other thing would you send an email
to all members of the committee
on how to access this information
okay we're
okay i'm going to open the public
hearing on house bill 1407-fn
an act encoding the promotion of
affordable housing under the land and
community heritage investment program
prime sponsor is representing clem
knight
representative clinton knight
you're going to introduce and explain
your bill
thank you um mr chair and thank you
to the ways and means committee for
listening to this
really important idea
i for the record i am representative
nicole klein knight representing
manchester hillsborough district 11.
this bill is not ready for prime time
i passed out an amendment to you to
convert this into a study committee
um but the idea and the tent is
really
well
intended to
basically allow
renters
to come together
and own
their
building and create equity
in
what we are seeing is a climate where
people cannot afford to to own homes and
even if they wanted to there's just a
shortage
so it was is not being funded correctly
in the current bill
and
they are adopting this in other states
but to make it perfectly fit with new
hampshire's
departments and to fund it properly we
would need to study this a little bit
further and since it is a
really
good idea i think there's merit in
studying this
and that's all i ask from the committee
today and i am completely open and
amenable to any amendments that you
so
2022-0178
h
yes
and to replace the bill as is yes
and so it will be a study committee yes
please
questions from the committee
representative
romney thank you
mr chair thank you for your testimony
can you just
you say it sounds like you you're saying
that other states have done something in
this arena
uh can you define exactly what a limited
equity
cooperative is
basically
it is
a land or a
an area such as an apartment building
that um
be purchased at rate value
by grants or other programs and then
sold back to the renters
at
market value or a lower rate that they
can afford
so that they can all
basically own the building together be
responsible for the taxes
and
basically it's it's like a version of
small home ownership but
so i'm just trying to understand so
let's say there's an apartment building
with 20 units
and
they managed to say yeah all the renters
say yeah we wish we could own this
building
and then we can
you know
charge itself well they have to pay for
that
but what you're saying is
they may or may not be able to finance
that
so they may be looking for other means
other grants or whatever to help them do
this so i i'm just is that am i
interpreting this correctly yes and
there are uh programs available for this
that we have not tapped into which is
why i think it's necessary to start
studying this and see
what we can accomplish and
give to our citizens at you know another
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman
uh representative klein knight have you
talked with the new hampshire community
loan fund which has been in this field
for quite a long time
and do you know something about the new
hampshire
very ancient at this point cooperative
law which includes housing
uh
and there are a fair number of
structures
jointly owned
around new hampshire
on that are in that group
as well as the
the
uh homeowners association
and the
condominiums
thank you for your question as i um
i want to go back to it because it was
kind of it i feel like it
it dissolved a little bit no offense but
you're saying did i work with
the loan housing
have you do you know what the new
hampshire community loan fund is yes in
fact they helped me write this amendment
okay and there isn't a program which is
why they've expressed interest in this
and that this bill isn't ready for prime
time and out of respect for all the
stakeholders this is why i'm proposing
this amendment change
thank you do you suppose you could have
them
talk to us
um we have an awful lot of experience in
this area i i suppose i can have um some
of the people that work over there yes
um and maybe they're even in the
audience today um what we're
experiencing though is a really low rate
of people testifying at the state house
as you've seen
and i i can't
control or force any of the people
that have been involved in any of the
legislation process this year to come
and testify unfortunately but
i can give you their information and
i
i'm sure they're always willing to have
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for being here today um
when you talk about uh the initial
funding of the purchase of the building
coming from a grant program how's that
grant funded in your eyes
it may be
from donors or federal funding
we have to take a look at what other
states are doing and how they're getting
their money and that's exactly what this
committee should do
thank
you representation
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative um
i i think at one point during your
testimony you said that it could be
purchased potentially for a little less
than market value
but
why would an owner sell it for less than
market value or did you mean the fact
that those grants would help it
be purchased more easily you're correct
um that the
the grants would purchase
at market value or however this
trust would be set up
they would be giving the seller market
rate value so the seller wouldn't be
losing any sort of money on this
and then what this is designed to do is
then resell it to a group of people that
maybe can't afford market rate value
further questions
alan
thank you and if you talk to the new
hampshire housing finance authority
which is at this point the chief source
of new hampshire-based housing funding
i may have there have been a lot of
meetings on this and a lot of
stakeholders
and um we have been meeting actually for
over a month going back and forth on
what would be the best course of action
this
wasn't ready for prime time and we had
discussed even pulling the bill but
because this is such an important idea
and has so much value to people in our
communities that
we cannot
you know
there's not enough supply to meet the
demand i think it would behoove us and
it would be a disservice if we just
didn't even look at all options
okay um
you
provided us with this amendment this
amendment completely changes it to a
study and it's very specific
what you want to study
it doesn't say
how how it's going to be financed or any
it says the benefit of utilizing limited
equity cooperatives to stabilize rents
etc
to use
the use in other states of limited
equity cooperatives to purchase
and
recommendations for future legislation
to facilitate the formation of limited
equity
so it's like starting
new right
and and yes and with all due respect mr
chair um
bringing those studies and those
stakeholders to the table for future
legislation i would hope that they would
give you the correct information on how
it should be studied to put in future
legislation okay
i think what would really
help i know would help me
consider this study proposal
would be
a communication it could be in writing
from
a community loan
that
provides information about limited
equity cooperatives and how
you know in a general way because of
studies of study study is supposed to
dig into this
this is an idea worth exploring so right
now we just have a few words and your
brief description
but we don't really have enough
i think to
go forward
without that kind of
background
yes thank you so much and i again as
stated at the beginning of my testimony
i'm open to amending this to include
um
key
stakeholders again i i don't want to
overuse that word but
the housing authority the finance
they can be a part of this committee and
i can go ahead to ols and redraft this
any further questions
thank you
if we were going to go forward with this
i think
we need something from the housing
finance authority and from the community
loan fund about how they think
this will be helpful
and
you either depend on us to try to make
of course um what is my yeah what how
long are you going to give me
and
am i understanding correctly that
you possibly don't trust the fact that i
got help writing this entire thing from
them
well we don't know
we only have you here because you say
they won't come but they could have sent
something
okay that's fine
and
for the matter of time if we all agree
we want to do something we're going to
exact next week but if we don't all
agree we're we've got until the 17th i
think it is of february
okay so can i un let me for
clarification you do agree that this is
a good idea but you don't want to move
forward until you get actual
confirmation from the people that helped
i don't think we're supposed to opine
but personally
i need more information
any further questions
if not we have
first one is brandon
larry
from the rights and democracy i believe
it says
good morning for the record my name is
brandon lemay i am from manchester new
hampshire and i am representing rights
and democracy
we are a grassroots group of members who
wish to engage both electorally
and on the policy side of things
so i also represent our manchester
housing work group called the manchester
housing alliance
and they were a big push behind
representative knight for sponsoring
this bill uh so i'd also like to thank
representative knight for um for
obliging us before you go any further
are you testifying for on the amendment
or the bill itself uh in the uh for the
amendment sorry thank you for asking
appreciate that
um
so yeah um we are actually looking to
start our own limited equity co-op um
and we got the idea for this bill when
we were talking with zachary palmer of
resident owned communities
who are associated with the community
loan fund
and i'd be happy to field any other
questions you have about limited equity
co-ops and land trusts
specifically the reason why we want to
just turn this into a study bill is
originally
a lot of the language was copied from
what vermont was doing
but after a lot of discussion with both
l-chip and other stakeholders we
realized that you know new hampshire
it's its own state and what works in
vermont isn't going to work in new
hampshire so a big reason why we want to
have this be a study is because we want
to see how we can best
synchronize this into the way our state
works
so yeah um
one thing i wanted to emphasize is
nationwide we have only about 200 000
uh residential units that are actually
ada compliant
and we see a huge need for those with
disabilities to have accessible housing
so big part of what we would be doing is
serving a lot of underserved uh folks
when it comes to housing
um also we want to serve those who are
making you know anywhere from like you
know zero percent to even like fifty
percent of like the uh
median income so
um i would be more than happy to take
any questions that you have um and also
be really happy to oblige to get
community loan fund uh involved here
representative romney thank you mr thank
you for your testimony
so it sounds like you're a group
not-for-profit i would imagine yep
um
sounds like your group is moving forward
without legislation
yeah
so
do we really need legislation for this i
mean forget about the study part of it
you know we can study this
but
why would we need legislation to make it
easier for you to do what you're going
to do or
yeah so when i was talking to financiers
for this um
some of which are uh not-for-profit uh
sources like the community loan fund but
also if we wanted to try to get any sort
of financing from like a private equity
firm
they would like to see some sort of
enabling legislation uh bankers like to
be a hundred percent sure uh when they
give money
uh so uh there's no there's nothing
saying that we can't do it but there's
also nothing saying that we can like
explicitly do it so uh they would like
to see some legislation in place
thank you for that clarification thank
you yeah further questions
representative elmy
thank you um
i work with homeowners associations
condominiums and
the few cooperatives that are are out
there
uh
in my other hat
and
there there is a cooperative law which
is very old now but which uh
includes all businesses but also
includes housing
uh it isn't terribly specific on housing
i don't know if you've looked through
that to see
where you think changes ought to be made
to
to um
allow this specific type of i don't know
what you mean actually about
the difference between limited equity
cooperative and a
a regular housing cooperative
uh yeah yeah um and to be honest um i'm
actually not entirely 100 sure of the
difference uh either i know that
specifically um there are just uh
different ways different grants that you
can get if you're a limited equity co-op
um and
this is exactly why i think we need to
study bill is so many states have done
so many different things
and we need to really assess what has
been done and what would really make
sense here
so actually appreciate you mentioning
that but yeah as you said i couldn't
find we couldn't find anything that was
like specifically you know enabling this
or
disallowing it
thank you for your testimony all right
thank you very much
sheila
representing the
nature conservatory
it's uh for the record it's sheila
vargas and i'm representing the nature
conservancy in new hampshire today thank
you chair
and
you're talking
about the bill or the amendment the
original bill um i have not had a chance
to see the amendment language
thank you
um so
as we can all agree l-chip is an
extremely popular program having not
seen the amendment language i'm not
going to be speaking to the amendment
i just wanted to come and urge the
committee to itl the original bill 1407
happy to take any questions as i said i
haven't seen the amendment language
housing affordability
is a huge issue as a young person living
in new hampshire i know that the nature
conservancy is not a housing
organization and so we thank the
sponsors for introducing
an amendment that does not include the
l-chip program because we don't see the
l-trip program as a savings account that
we can withdraw from to put a band-aid
over
other issues that frankly are not in the
statute so i will be respectful of the
committee's time leave it at that and i
urge the committee to itl the original
bill thank you happy to answer any
questions
thank you for your testimony
representative sean mr chairman uh
so you're just talking about the l-chip
savings account the ability to
get into it to use for
this
equity housing
correct and i i'm speaking to it
in opposition of that because the
original bill text was seeking to expand
the scope of the l-chip program to fund
affordable housing and while affordable
housing is a critically important issue
in the state we don't feel that l-chip
would be that uh source of funding
especially because the number of
applicants for l-chip keeps increasing
every year and there are not enough
funds in the l-chip program to actually
meet the demand right now so essentially
the original bill pulling from l-chip to
fund affordable housing would be a tiny
tiny band-aid on what we can all agree
is a massive issue
thank you
representative romney followed by
representative almighty
thank you mr chair thank you for your
testimony
yeah so yeah i i can say i'm looking at
at line five of the original bill it
says because currently your mission is
natural cultural and historic resources
and then they tacked on promotion of
affordable housing for residents
correct that's way astray i guess is it
would you it's your view that this is
way astray of the original purpose of
l-chip uh yes in my humble opinion it is
okay thank you
representative
thank you i just wanted to agree that
aside from the financial part of this it
would cost
l-chip an enormous amount of time effort
and new personnel to deal with an issue
that they do not deal with at all
which is very complicated
yes thank you representative and i just
want to be transparent with the
committee when we saw the bill released
we were very concerned and so we did
reach out to the bill sponsors we have
been communicating with them they did
indicate that l-chip is not the best way
to go about this and so while we
appreciate them looking for a solution
and looking to a program like l-chip
which
is incredibly effective and incredibly
popular it really should be a template
for them not the savings account that
representative malloy
this may be a question of the committee
or the chair what is the amount in the
l-chip
what's the preparation now for that does
anybody recall
did you say that again what is the l
chip uh balance what is the
appropriation for l-chip right now
would you know what
i believe we have the executive director
how much
any further
questions sent on thank you for testing
thank you very much for your time
anybody else wishes to testify for or
uh
paul would you check see
thank you
anybody else wish to testify for or
against house bill 1407
and i'm closing the public hearing on
1407.
any of the general announcements
i think yeah everybody
he said we said about next to thursday
right
wednesday
three
just just for the committee information
uh we have scheduled a
work work session on all the house bills
for next wednesday
republicans are going to be
we have a poll going to figure out when
we can
meet monday or tuesday probably is
the time okay
and
what we need to do
is that we have one early bill and
that's house bill
nursing homes
the 25 million dollars and the 15
million annually
uh
i would like
both parties
to give us some thought
and
what do we want to do with that because
yes represent aims is that
that movement the need to
report out the early bill by that date
um
because
i've heard on the 15th yes
and that's why it moved up from the
17th through the to the 10th so that
will be in the calendar i guess uh
tomorrow tonight yeah you should see
that information in the next calendar
yeah
okay so uh give us some serious
thought what do we want to do with 15 25
do we need to have work sessions on it
do we need an amendment or are we ready
mr chair
so then on the 26th the rest of the
bills will be just work session bills
with the committee here right no
executive session on that those other
bills
what i'm hoping is that if
both
parties after they have their caucuses
agree on certain bills
that we can accept those bills
on that day
and if we don't agree
then we decide we're going to have
either subcommittees etc thank you
i think we need more information right
yeah
but are we exacting the county bill
only only if
both sides are
in agreement if not then we're going to
have to uh schedule a
to work the bill
so we're reporting the bill out by the
10th
and there's a session on the 15th right
so we need to get that bill out
and if we can
agree on what we want to do on the other
bills
we'll execute those
uh next wednesday
mr chair may i ask uh
is there
any additional is that one of the bills
that we need additional information on
and if we could have the appropriate
parties here to help i i can't recall
do your homework review the bills that
you think
it would help to bring somebody into
these work sessions give us additional
information let's do it at that point in
time
clarify it
so we can make a decision on it fine
if it doesn't
and we need to
do a separate subcommittee or works
work sessions as a whole
we'll do it
do we do we have a um time for the
tuesday
republican caucus
yes at 10 o'clock
okay i sent that email out this morning
okay well
we can take a break until
10 30.
has anyone on our side not
that's here not filled out the
poll yet you could go and do it right
now
thank you
okay
so
uh
my fault
yeah
foreign
so
um
yes
uh
wait
i noticed the parking garage has a
charging station
yeah so there's somebody getting their
so
oh
foreign
okay
for the first time in my life
a few months ago and the doctor is
that's
[Music]
[Music]
is
uh
um
oh
so one day
there's going to be a session on
february
[Music]
that'll come out
tonight
will be
um
now
okay i want to
open the public hearing
is establishing a deferral from the
business profits tax and business
enterprise tax or qualified limited
sponsor representative abramson is here
so representative
if you want to introduce and explain
[Music]
sorry about that
uh my name is uh
representative max abramson i'm
representing hampton hampton falls and
seabrook
uh this is house bill i'm introducing
house bill 1541
uh which is intended to
allow
new businesses new startups
the opportunity to
simply file their initial
llc filing without having to pay any fee
and
uh get a five-year exemption from from
their annual 100
a year
uh filing fee this is a bill that's
meant for really really small startups
um we've talked about uh you know the
hollywood tax credit that keeps coming
up and i remember thinking you know we
have the army tax credit and we have
these
um tax credit ideas for really big
business and i thought uh
you know there are also a lot of really
small businesses apple computers started
up literally out of a garage with
with next to nothing they had only a few
thousand dollars
when they started up and started making
the apple apple one
which was just a computer kit
but they're also in you know small
independent films where i work
and
uh
you know rock bands that that
literally the only assets they have is
their is their musical gear
um i was part of a uh for a while a game
development uh startup company and those
companies are starting with uh virtually
no
revenue to speak of and no initial
assets to speak of so
money's tight
the
the the three things that the bill is
proposing to do is give you that
five-year exemption from having to pay
the annual filing fee
it exempts you for five years from the
business enterprise tax and it allows
you to defer for five years the business
profits tax
i'm not sure if legislative services
stuck to that
meticulously this went through about
four different redrafts
to try to get the the exact language
that i was trying to get and uh
i think they even suggested that i might
have to go through another redraft or a
committee amendment in the end but um
that that was the intent the intent was
where you have very very small
businesses
that
that don't have money that can't afford
to sit down with an attorney
where you have
several different entrepreneurs
from around new england
i thought that it would be a good idea
if one of them could say
hey i live in new hampshire and we have
this easy llc startup
approach where you don't have to pay any
filing fees at all initially and you can
defer whatever your not only your taxes
but you can defer your tax filings for
up to five years
so since most of these
really small startups shoestring
startups uh
never
either never turn a profit or never make
enough money to justify
turning into a full-size business i felt
that
this would be
a pretty good alternative
for
for companies that maybe only have a
small percentage chance of of ever
making it big
um
i've talked with some members of the
committee and i've talked with people
downstairs in the uh in the state house
and
budgeting office and
dra and whatnot and
they've liked the general concept
of having some kind of tax deferment or
tax exemption for new startups of course
new york state has the most famous
startup plan which is that they get a
10-year complete tax exemption but they
have lots and lots of restrictions on
that and they have to stay
in new york state over the long run but
this is looking at the fact that
that in new england you can have several
entrepreneurs and they can be in
different states but we want to have as
many of those new startups start up in
new hampshire as possible so that they
then gradually grow expand create jobs
and and maybe convert to a different llc
or s or c corporation
so that was the that was the intent of
the bill is just to
uh recognize that those types of
startups aren't aren't necessarily going
to be generating any revenue for a while
um certainly won't be generating very
big profits for a while but we want to
kind of maximize the number of new
startups that are attempted here in new
hampshire
okay thank you for your testimony would
you take questions
sure thing
representative thank you mr chair
thank you max um
so you have section three in the bill
too establishing a study committee
can you explain what the purpose of that
is please uh that was added in by
uh legislative services and they didn't
give me a clear explanation for why they
wanted to have a study committee added
into it but that was their decision okay
further questions
representative
thank you mr chairman so
dra would have no cognizance of
these startups
for five years is that the way it would
operate
no they would file with the secretary of
state corporate division and they would
they would actually have a corporate
filing but they wouldn't
uh in most cases they wouldn't uh do the
100 a year annual
filing and and part of the reason for
that is
that there are lots and lots of garage
band startups there are lots of small
businesses that
never amount to anything
and so it did it didn't make sense
from my viewpoint to
kind of flood the secretary of state's
office and the um
the dra with with filings for companies
that aren't yet profitable and aren't
likely to be
profitable soon
mr chairman follow-up follow-up i'm a
little confused i never knew we had a
filing fee
in
dra
and the person behind you is shaking his
head are you sure you're not talking
about the one in
in the department of state
they when i talked to the secretary of
state's office actually when i talked to
the
uh
the corporate division they said that
there's a 100 a year filing fee
even if you don't make any money you
still have to file that fee every single
year
yeah
it's in the secretary of state's office
it's not in dra
right
um so you would be what you really want
to do is to exempt
the filing fee in the corporate
and then
in
dra exempt
bet for five years and defer the bpt to
the fifth or sixth year correct
and do you
know
about on
particularly restaurants
that
they very frequently start as llc's
and very frequently die within the first
five years and restart immediately
thereafter as a different restaurant
yeah i'd see a lot i actually see a lot
of turnover in seabrook we've had
in fact there are certain
locations that look good but that every
single business that opens up at certain
locations ends up closing down usually
within three or four or five years
so if those are locations that are never
going to generate a profit they're not
doesn't stop someone from trying
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question my question is simple
if if this is a
an exemption of the fee but a deferral
of the tax
what would then happen to the llc or the
startup that
fails after three years are they going
to be forgiven for the
the taxes that would have accrued over
those three years or
well if they fail they're not there
there's no business profits tax
to pay if they're if their net earnings
over five years is negative
then there's no tax to be there's no tax
liability to be paid to the state in
that case anyway
but if they did
have any if they started off strong and
then failed within that five-year period
and they didn't pay the bet would they
then be responsible for it they would
never be responsible for the first five
years of bet that's the exemption that's
in the bill
um and then the bpt is what is what gets
deferred deferred
i talked to legislative services and i i
tried to get them to include a provision
saying
that that business in order to maintain
this has to maintain
um
the
sufficient liquidity sufficient sellable
assets to cover whatever their their
outstanding tax liability might be great
representatives did you have your hand
up
good morning i think
yeah good morning
um
i'm not uh maybe i'm missing this but um
the the
the proposed bill provides for a tax
deferral
for any tax for a period of five years
it's it's that's how it's stated
shall be granted the tax deferral for a
period of five years
and then
to be qualified for that
it has to be a qualified llc
with a payroll of no more than a hundred
thousand dollars per year
so
if they get the deferral
they're entitled to it because they've
they get a five-year exemption but then
what if their payroll goes up
in the third year
are they still quite are they still
eligible
uh if something happens in the third
year where they need more full-time
employees and they go over the one
hundred thousand dollar limit then they
would no longer at that point continue
to be a qualified llc so they'd have the
deferment for the first three years but
they could they wouldn't get it for the
full five years at the at that three
year point where they need to exceed
that they're no longer one of these
little tiny
startups say now okay so that's the
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative
i want to make sure i understand how
much value this is going to add because
if i'm if i'm not mistaken the current
bet tax doesn't kick in until 150 k
so you don't even have to worry about
this 100 k limit it's not going to kick
in to 150 and then as far as the bpt
that was increased i believe it's
somewhere around 92 k until you
have at least 92 000 in profits or
thereabouts there's no bpt tax
so isn't that isn't the current law
enough
to
be able to get somebody going without
having paying taxes well the payroll and
revenue are two different things i'm
assuming this is this is a business that
can have
two or three or four entrepreneurs
uh starting in there and i assume that
they're going to be working full-time i
you know obviously envisioned i'm not
you know in seabrook so we have a lot of
landscaping roofers plow businesses
and they're usually family businesses so
they don't necessarily have a large
payroll but if they if they had you know
two plow trucks if they had two work
trucks i could i could foresee them
having you know certainly well over a
hundred thousand dollars in revenue but
they're going to have the whole family
working it
um
so it's possible to not have any payroll
at all and just have a family-owned
business
that's going for several years and they
could have
over five years they could potentially
have close to a million dollars in total
you know they could have two hundred
thousand dollars a year in
in total revenue coming in
and uh just be working the business
themselves or an automotive shop or a
collision shop or
or any type of business like that just
when they're first getting started and
they have it they haven't hired more
than maybe one or two employees
um they're they're pretty small they
might have relatively high revenue
um
but if if there is in fact some type of
business profits that that just that
business profits would be deferred and
the bet would be exempt
so under under current law that
particular bit type of business right
now might have some bet
liability
it's
for a lot of brand new startups um where
they're not familiar with the business
enterprise tax and especially people who
have just moved here
or if they have
three or four people and only one of
them lives in new hampshire and none of
them is an expert on the bet the b-e-t
can be kind of confusing and it can
discourage people from setting up a
business here
follow-up
follow-up so on the bpt when you say
deferred
um so if if
it gets added to so after five years
couldn't it suddenly
become something that it's that in
itself could hurt them because now they
suddenly have to pay this chunk of
money after five years
yeah it is it that's true but it is
better being able being able to defer a
tax especially when
the state tax
is deductible on your federal tax as a
cost
the ability to
defer you know you don't have to take
the full five year deferment you could
take a three or four year deferment
whatever ends up being most advantageous
on your on your your federal tax returns
so if you can take a larger
cost say in your fourth year you may be
able to save
quite a bit of money on your your
federal tax return
thank you
i have a question
the hundred thousand dollars
on payroll
what does that include
does that include uh the benefits of the
social security and all that
um that was just meant to in sorry that
was just meant to include
um
the
actual payroll the actual wages
uh in the same way that we uh
account for it when you're figuring out
uh
um social security wages or unemployment
wages that calculation on your
should have been spelled out as wages
then
okay
it
when you have two people
it's hard to
keep a payroll
under a hundred thousand dollars
if if they're going to be
why did you pick a hundred thousand i
initially i was gonna say none i was
gonna say zero if you wanted to have you
know an independent contractor or
contract some of the work out
um and i i i kind of thought this
through i'm trying to say this is for
really small companies that don't even
have any employees but someone might
hire
get at some point during the year they
have to hire a secretary they have to
hire a truck driver to make deliveries
or do do some type of work and i said
well there's got to be a you know a cap
you can't just have it be
you know a billion dollar fab lab or
something like that i didn't want to
have big business
um taking advantage of this
and you know not paying any
tax at all this is meant for like for
really really small home-based
businesses
and businesses that just have one small
simple shop it's it's actually not meant
to have
for them to have employees at all but if
they were gonna hire someone temporary
or seasonal or have two people working
that didn't want them to just suddenly
automatically lose this tax deferment
just on that
representative brown you have a question
yes i do
thank mr chair uh thank uh thanks for
the question again
so
i'm more concerned about the mechanics
of how this would work
uh
i would assume that they have to file
each year a return
for the dra to keep track of
of any profits that they do make no
let's say the five year period
but you know but that's number one uh
so you would agree that they'd have to
file each year correct
what dras mentioned in the in their
uh analysis is that it would be
sufficient to take whatever your federal
tax filing is and send them a copy of
that okay that would be fine
and then the funny thing in our state is
you know the interplay between the bet
and the bpt
i'm not i'm not going to try to
articulate how whether there's an impact
i think we need to hear from the dra how
that
all plays out
or even whether it's advantageous
uh to the filer and
to to to have this to to use this
because of the interaction of bpt and
bet
well one offset's the other
but i guess you're already offsetting
that you have to pay the bet so i guess
that's a benefit well
my thing was most most
states don't have a business enterprise
tax there are some unusual taxes that
they have in other states and there are
a few things that we don't have in new
hampshire
but sometimes when you have
people looking at putting together
startup and they're thinking you know
massachusetts or new hampshire or
they're thinking maine or new hampshire
if they're looking at the possibility of
being hit with a tax liability that they
don't understand that's confusing and
they don't have somebody they don't have
a legislator there to explain it um
sometimes they'll say i don't even
understand what this is so we don't know
what the worst case scenario is so they
end up just they'll they would file in
another state
you know better the devil you know than
the one that you don't
um and i've had to explain the bet even
to people who
you know and
how it how it uh
whatever business enterprise tax you pay
is credited towards your business
profits tax and i've had to explain that
to people even who've lived here their
whole lives and it can be a little bit
confusing um if you're not used to it
thank you
any further questions
oh
representative
uh
phelps first
thank you mr chair um
and thank you representative for taking
my question
um
i
am representative hacken phillips from
grafton county district 12 but i also
serve um as a
practicing corporate and business law
lawyer so you might say that i'm
familiar with forming new business
entities
with that context i just wanted to let
you know i have a few concerns with your
bill
primarily because
of some of the language that's included
which i think may have been or may lead
to unintended consequences
um so
to begin with i i would just like to ask
um
why
have you authored the bill that only
deals with
llcs and not other business entities
here in the state
uh it's just it was just a draft idea
as
we had conversations last year about
this bill
with other members of the committee and
it was just to propose something to get
an idea in front of the committee
this committee has talked about
some type of startup
you know tax exemption or something over
the years and we kind of had it
most of the members who've been here for
a while want to have actual language in
front of them
you know like an actual bill before they
start rewriting something rather than
just having something that's conceptual
so it really needed to have a bill come
in and i i thought that an llc
llcs tend to have a lot of tax and
liability benefits so i see a lot of
businesses start up as an llc right now
so that's why i went with the ll easy
llc or qualified llc startup okay um but
um just as a matter of comment it may be
worth considering other business
entities as well as llc's
the other another issue that i've
i'm concerned about
um
well uh let's just head to the sect or i
guess page two roman numeral four it's
on line four
this is the section that speaks about
when a termination for this deferral
might occur
and i'm concerned that um particularly
with the permissive language here
it seems to me that if a business uh
falls out of satisfying the requirements
it should automatically terminate uh
rather than be possible um
given that you know we are a revenue
committee
seeking to help support our state
function
by collecting those revenues so i don't
believe we should leave it up to an llc
to to determine whether or not it should
qualify um
so maybe that's something to consider
did you notice that language issue
before no what i said what i suggested
to legislative services was that that
the
exemption and the deferment would only
be maintained as long as they continue
to qualify and then if there were some
calendar year that came along where they
maybe exceeded the hundred thousand
dollars for payroll or
um
failed on some qualification that they
would then have to
change that year to a different type of
llc or a different type of incorporation
so i guess
it's worth noting that your intent is
not translated here
in this language that wouldn't be the
first time
yeah
and then another issue that i have um
just down in the
thank you mr chair a follow-up thank you
um
just in the third section where you're
talking about the committee being
established um
uh you state in the third roman numeral
that the committee shall study the
procedure for formation of llc companies
in ways in which the process could be
simplified or modified
to support business startups
are are you aware of
the simplicity of the current llc
formation capabilities on the secretary
of state's website in which um it's
simply
electronic submission
that does not require
even legal counsel to do so
it's just a matter of filling out a few
fields and paying a fee
i actually went through that process
with a startup
and it did require several calls to
the secretary of state's office to their
corporate division
and
the
100 a year filing fee
to refile every year
was
a little bit
surprising to me
how do i say this
if you really had a business that's
really running on a shoestring that
hundred dollars a year every year is
is
you know something that they might spend
on signs or something that might be
trying to spend on software or buying a
new laptop
um
or buying you know new musical gear for
a band
um
when you have businesses that are
starting up on a real real shoestring
and it's it's
i don't want to say it's for fun but
it's just it's it's
it's
unlikely that the business is going to
be profitable
you're you're
you're taking lots and lots of
businesses
that are running on a shoestring and
their their
their ultimate success rate is pretty
low
so i'm trying to just
exempt them from any feed that i that i
possibly can under this
to kind of give them the best shot
possible of finally breaking even and
maybe maybe growing into something maybe
actually employing people and hiring
their first 5 or 10 people and
doing something but
when they're when they're first starting
out every single dollar is
you know kind of critical
to uh
you know
i i had a i had a business that was uh
literally i think it was in a flea
market and i i think my
revenues were about 100 or 200 a weekend
so
um they're they're running on a real
shoestring and the chance of a a
business like that being can you speak
under the mic oh i'm sorry
i i had a business one time that had
gross revenues of literally like one or
two hundred dollars per weekend
in total sales and net profits were
pretty much zero for that business
um and it's just keeping the thing open
and trying to see if that business can
can somehow
you know expand and uh
build some type of customer base and
thank you mr chair no further questions
i think it would just be a lot of
conversation
mr chair thank you mr chair i'd like to
ask
representative hacken phillips could you
re-identify those two areas you
mentioned
because i'm looking for roman numeral
four on page two and i see roman numeral
six on page two oh i'm sorry
it's roman numeral six i apologize i
must read that uh it's just
line four okay page two
and then um
i was looking at uh the third section
about the committee in roman numeral
three on line thirty
two thirty one three two
on page two
oh i see it now thank you
thank you mr chairman uh what
do you do about on
cases like an entrepreneur that we have
in my
city which who
uh
carries about
20 to
llcs in his portfolio he
he puts every single um
store or whatever he's doing in a
separate llc to protect them which is
common practice actually
um
and
on so
he at any one time is likely to have
several of these startups does he
qualify
because each one of them is considered a
tax entity
each one each one would qualify for the
tax deferment um
the reason i went for a tax deferment is
i
i look at law in terms of how would
somebody abuse it if they really you
know if they're really trying to abuse
the system
i don't think that law especially on
commerce i don't think that law is good
unless somebody's really tried to you
know scrutinize it and make sure that uh
it it's hard to take advantage of
and i i could foresee
you know
there are some people who have 10 20
different llc's right now and they would
try to take advantage of whatever tax
exemption or tax credits that we come up
with
so that's why i thought a tax deferment
where they're they're deferring the
business profits tax
but at the same time they're still going
to be paying the interest so he'll get
to the end of the five years and they'll
still owe the tax
um
he won't
he wouldn't completely get out of paying
any tax he would still pay the business
profits tax if if he has a profitable
company
follow-up and so
if he
uh he is not paying the bet
so he would have to pay full freight on
the bpt at five years unless
he
cuts that business takes that business
out and replaces it with something else
is that the way it would work well but
he would have filed federal
tax returns also and if say that he had
had a hundred thousand and
profits on a particular llc every year
for five years
um he's still going to have some tax
liability on that on that llc so by the
end of the five years
it's it's deferred but it's it's still
accumulated the tax liability is still
against him
yes
as i look at this bill i see deferral
for both the bet and the bbt i'm not
seeing exemption
it's supposed to be an exemption for the
business enterprise tax and a deferral
on the business profits tax well
can you point to the language that
uh legislative services might have aired
this is like i say this is the fourth
draft of this
bill so some of the earlier drafts did
have
an exemption from bet so
okay so i just want to point out an
amendment to the committee that the
dra note
uh speaks of deferral
not exemption
and therefore concludes that basically
there's a timing issue here which may be
an incomplete conclusion by the way
but not and not a
loss due to an exemption and in the bill
any further questions
i have a pink card from
dan mcguire representing the
granite state taxpayers in opposition to
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is dan
mcguire i'm here representing granite
state taxpayers
i'm here today mostly to talk about the
following bill but i figured
this bill is somewhat similar to things
i've testified on the past that i'll
just briefly
explain why we we would oppose it
and
all my remarks are about sections one
and two section three we have no opinion
on it might very well be a good idea i
don't know
um
so this is
it seems similar to i've testified in
the past here against the research and
development tax credit
which is a special purpose kind of tax
credit for for particular kinds of
businesses and it seems to us that this
is somewhat similar it's it's a special
purpose
tax break whether it's deferral or
exemption that we can talk about that
but but it's a special purpose
to code for a particular kind of
business
and and in general
we're much more in favor of uniform
taxes applied to all
in a certain category in all businesses
rather than
special breaks for this kind for that
kind that sort of thing right um if you
pass this kind of of a of a special
purpose
tax law
it it only encourages others to say wait
a minute
why don't you give me a special thing
you know i'm very worthy and so on and
and so
you start fighting over who is more
worthy than who else and all that sort
of thing it's it's much more beneficial
to just have a uniform
low tax rate for everyone
um and not try to pick winners and
losers and so that's why we're opposed
to this
thank you well thank you for your
testimony dan
mcguire mr mcguire
representative
i'll just ask
do you see constitutional issues in this
um thank you for the question
representative i really
uh didn't think about it but
thank you
dan
anybody else wish to testify for or
nothing
okay
last time anybody else wished to testify
for or against house bill 1541 since
none
we have seven minutes before the next
bill
it's half baked
and it's an interesting
something's in the bill that
that you're uncomfortable with uh
you made a mistake on you blame it on
the
he said
they required as you said he he's the
huh
um
okay
uh
duties
i want to start the public hearing on
house bill
1478-fn dash a
an act relative to the business process
tax applicable to certain large low-wage
employer
and the prime sponsor is
represented adjutant
and
representative
introduce your bill and explain it all
right
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee microphone is on i remember
that this
time um i am here to introduce
hb 1478
which is
in my opinion aptly called the stop
corporate welfare act
um
i
wish
that i had come up with uh this
monologue
um but
it's said far better um in this clip
that i have right here uh that with the
permission of the chair i'd like to play
for the committee because i think it
helps illustrate my point
what is it you want to do i just i have
a little one minute video clip here that
i think makes an illustrated point and
uh it's in the voice of somebody that
uh i think members of the committee
would appreciate uh and it would very
much help my testimony if i could play
it
i will
that's enough to make him the richest
man in the world by far and possibly the
richest human being in all of human
history
it's certainly enough to pay his
employees well
but he doesn't a huge number of amazon
workers are so poorly paid they qualify
for federal welfare benefits according
to data from the nonprofit group new
food economy nearly one in three amazon
employees in arizona for example was on
food stamps last year
jeff bezos isn't paying his workers
enough to eat so you made up the
difference with your tax dollars next
time you see jeff bezos make certain
that he says thank you
what about the walton family they
founded walmart collectively they're
worth about 175 billion dollars that's
more than the entire gross domestic
product of qatar the oil rich gulf state
the waltons could certainly afford to be
generous with their workers instead they
count on you to take up the slack in
2013 taxpayers sent more than six
billion dollars to walmart's employees
for food stamps medicaid and housing
assistance
and if you think that's remarkable meet
travis kalanick he's the youthful
founder of uber
his personal fortune is close to five
billion dollars
his drivers by considering
less than minimum wage
a little bit but the point is made um
that
um this is an issue that reaches pretty
far across the political spectrum
i
did not frankly think that there was
going to be an issue that mr carlson and
i would agree on
but this is a point that he started
raising in 2018 about the issue where
large employers are
have the capacity to pay their employees
um pretty well
but don't so that they're subsidized
through medicaid and food stamps
and that's what this bill is looking to
go after
we're looking to stop uh what is often
deemed corporate welfare the mechanism
by which
large corporations don't pay well enough
that their employees qualify for
benefits when they could otherwise be
paid well
this bill only applies to businesses
over 100 employees so we wanted to set
the bar very high as to avoid um the
perception that we were putting an
onerous regulation on small businesses
and the bill says you can either pay
a point five percent uh increase in the
business profits tax as part of the
corporate welfare tax
or
you can pay everybody fifteen dollars an
hour in your store at least um
my understanding is that if you take a
company like walmart uh which i have a
little first-hand experience with
um i worked there for about a month in
between jobs in 2021
i personally as a truck unloader made
about 16 an hour so i wouldn't qualify
for this um however
a lot of the cashiers a lot of the
front-end folks are still paid less than
fifteen dollars an hour if you're a
company the size of walmart um or any
other those uh more than 100 employee
stores
you're going to be paying less paying
people the 15 an hour minimum then you
would be paying the increase in the
corporate profits tax and the business
profits tax um so it's an if or
um we want to provide that option but we
also really do want to crack down on
corporate welfare because
um it's a
pretty overwhelmingly popular uh issue
to deal with that problem that's what
this bill hopes to do
um and i would ask that the committee
consider an otp recommendation and send
it to the floor so that's what i got
happy to take questions
thank you for your testimony
representative
first questions from representative lang
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question so
i guess my ques my big question is how
do we get over the constitutionality and
the new hampshire constitutionality of
this issue if you understand part
part two article five of our
constitution
which the title says it's about the
legislature form of government is to
make laws elect officers to find their
powers duties impose fines assess taxes
prohibit from the authorizing towns of
certain aid well i'll talk strictly
about the tax component when it talks
about taxes it says and to impose and
levy proportional and reasonable
assessments rates and taxes upon the
inhabitants of the and the residents
within this state
so when i read that that
part of the constitution what you're
proposing to do is create two different
tax rates for different classes of
employers if you're over a hundred
people but paying less than 15 you're
going to pay one tax rate and if you're
over a hundred and paying more than 15
you're going to pay a different tax rate
doesn't that not meet the equal and
proportional standard is set in our
constitution with a levy of taxes
i wouldn't interpret that that way
because uh we have different tax rates
for different taxes
um i might just disagree with the
interpretation on that uh but my
interpretation of that language would
still hold that this is constitutional
follow
oh
i'm sorry could you i'm trying to
understand how he gets the
constitutional and and i and i
understand we might disagree on what
equal and proportional is it although a
plain read it seems pretty clear that if
you have an entity
that is the same
they 100 their business with 100
employees but you're going to tax them
differently based on their corporate
policy and i'm trying to understand how
you think that that's equal and
proportional and it overcomes the
constitutional hurdle right uh well
correct me if i'm wrong because i am uh
one of the few legislators that will
come to hearings and admit that i don't
know everything but uh we
have a standard by which businesses are
required to pay the business profits tax
not every business in the state of new
hampshire pays the business profits tax
has to do with their size and their
revenue share
i think a similar agreement can be made
here
and as such if i were trying to reason
with it i would presume that it is
constitutional
thank you mr chair
thank you mr chair thank you for your
testimony i have the same basic
problem
that that i think there's a
constitutional issue here as well
you know if i'm i'm company one that
makes widgets i'm company in this
company too that makes widgets one
company pays their employees 12 hours an
hour
another company pays them 16
an hour so i guess the differentiation
is
in terms of the class
would be the salary
i don't know i don't know if we want to
go down that route but
again
i i
i guess i'll have to make it up would
you believe that this there could be a
constitutional problem here
i
personally
don't think so because of the standard
that i laid out to representative lang
about we already have capacity quotas
for who pays the business profits tax
there's already a line drawn between
businesses who do pay it in businesses
that don't pay it what i'm just
suggesting is that we enhance the line a
little bit and make it a little firmer
so i think
if that's the case then you'd have to
rule the business profits tax and it's
entirely unconstitutional that's just my
opinion i'm not a lawyer but that's what
i would read it as
reps unknown
thank you mr chairman um representative
thank you for your testimony um is this
a model legislation from somewhere else
it doesn't seem that it's written
familiarly like we would see be written
here did this come from somewhere else
uh the so i can provide a little context
representative and thank you for the
question um in 2018 there was a federal
bill filed called the stop bezos act um
and if my recollection is correct the
ana the acronym is uh
it bottoming
i'm not gonna get it right um but the
point is um it did come from a senate
bill it was aimed to create a very
complex structure to where
um the federal government would charge
those massive employers uh the dollar
per dollar
um return that uh those companies
employees were receiving in the medicaid
and food stamp reimbursement um
tried to construct something like that
in the state of new hampshire
after attempting that i believe it would
have created too much of an onerous
responsibility on hhs
and the administrative agencies who do
allow those benefits to track that and
reimburse that
so this just seemed like a far more
streamlined process
representative
thank you
under our tax law
businesses each business is an entity
so i've got
a friend with on
20-something
llcs each of them is an entity
not considering them as all belonging to
him
but on
under our constitution
we have to
to have broad-based taxes equal
proportional
across unless
we have a reasonable argument which the
court will accept
which says that
there is a good
reason that the legislature
has
exempted
a particular group and
the only way we've really used this
is
to put a floor
which is mostly for administrative
purposes that it costs us more to
collect
than it would to
on
to um
then it would we would get out of it
on
all it originated i believe
as the concept that
if you are going to tax this business or
person into
the poor farm we are going to have to
and
that is a very different
thing which is i think is what my
colleagues are trying are saying to you
that's a very different kind of
rationale of exemption than the one
you're trying to
to put in
now
do you agree
yes do you agree with that
um
i appreciate the context i'm going to
maintain
my original position is that i would
still hold that this would be
constitutional
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh as far as the classification of
businesses or no
any tax that a business is charged by
the state
who ultimately pays that tax i i
understand where you're going with that
question
uh the i my understanding is that where
you're going with that question is
uh that would ultimately be picked up by
the consumers is that
okay
i'll follow up mr
that therefore would mean that imposing
this tax on a business
who didn't pay 15 an hour
charging more for the product that they
were
selling making their product less
appetizing on the market as we heard it
in an earlier bill than would be
a larger business making the same
product
well i
with all due respect uh representative
vollery um
because i understood where the question
was going didn't mean that i agreed with
the premise
um
i there has to be a way to go after
corporate welfare um i think it is an
indefensible system where large
corporations are able to
essentially bankroll programs like
medicaid and social security and food
stamps into their own bottom line
um
maybe
this isn't the perfect way but i think
it's the best effort that i've seen
speaking a little biasedly there
um but there's just there's got to be a
way to do it um
you know you can
technically any tax or anything is you
know can be moved down the line uh to
the next person but
i do believe that the issue of corporate
welfare is a really really big issue and
one that needs to be gone after happy to
work with any member of the committee
who has any other ideas on how to
address this um because you know there
is even in conservative realms
opposition to this kind of uh practice
but um this is what i got and i will try
to defend it the best i can
further questions
mr chair
one follow-up okay follow up
if you don't mind sir
are you aware that the new hampshire
median wage is 65
or about 32 an hour
yes i am i am also aware that there are
corporations that would be
um
categorized under this bill as
applicable and attack in the tax who do
pay less than 15 an hour and as a
consequence their employees are eligible
for benefits that they do not need to be
eligible for because those corporations
thank you mr chairman any further
questions saying none thank you for your
um called dan mcguire representing the
granite state taxpayers
thank you very much mr chairman for the
record my name is dan mcguire i'm here
on behalf of granite state taxpayers
um
our opposition to this bill starts right
on line one
uh the actual be known as a stop
corporate welfare act
i mean
that's got to be one of the silliest
things i've ever read in a bill
to characterize a tax that is uniform
across all businesses
as welfare for particular businesses or
welfare in general
i mean that is just silly
um
you know is the fact that we tax
cigarettes and hotel rooms but we don't
tax shampoo is that somehow welfare for
procter and gamble
you know it just doesn't make sense so i
would hope that even if
on the unlikely event that you find this
ought to pass you would at least
get rid of that silliness all right but
the the bill itself
is basically trying to shoehorn
the minimum wage argument into our tax
code
um minimum wage is something that's
regularly
argued in the legislature
every session
and it's very common and it goes
different ways at different times
but
it's it's a it's something that's
there's a whole committee dedicated to
those kinds of issues the labor
committee and it's something that is
very much appropriate there
and not here
um
in
to somehow
um
get into taxes and and and
and try to
um control something that is much easier
more easily handled in in another venue
this is just inappropriate i mean this
particular bill i'm i you know i i don't
really want to get into
arguing the minimum wage itself i
i remember
making a floor speech on it once myself
but
um
but it's just
let's not
kind of pollute our tax code with with
special purpose things that are much
more easily handled in other parts
of the rsis
thank you thank you for your testimony
take questions
questions
next is dave gervais from the bia
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is dave
giuve i'm a senior vice president with
the business and industry association we
are here in opposition to this bill
and i'd like to divide my comments into
two different buckets or silos the first
is is this good public policy
and the second is if it is good public
policy are there issues that will need
to be addressed
i would like to suggest this is bad
public policy and i'll explain why
although there are some states around
the country whose constitutions do allow
different
tax rates
none of them that i'm aware of are
basing those tax rates on whether a
single job within a corporation or
company is paying 15 an hour or less
so the message you would be sending to
the rest of the country if you pass this
bill is if you're a large employer we
don't want you here we don't want you
and we don't want the jobs that you
would be bringing here
so i suggest just on that merit alone
that you would find this to be an
expedient however if you think it is
good public policy then here's some
questions i think you need to consider
the first is why is this just limited to
the business profits tax there are many
larger employers around the state in the
non-profit sector and in the service
sector
that have more than a hundred employees
that are likely paying less than fifteen
dollars an hour for some of their uh
positions there are only business
enterprise taxpayers they don't pay the
business profits tax why are they exempt
from this
how would a company that is a business
profits taxpayer be treated if they had
a hundred uh and one employees one of
whom
received a
wage of less than 15 an hour
but then throughout the course of the
year they lost several employees and now
they're at 99 employees how would their
tax be treated
and secondly
how would you justify a company that is
a hundred employees that has one
individual making 15 an hour or less
and you have another company that has 99
employees
50 of whom make 50 15 an hour or less
one would be paying the higher tax but
not the other how is that justifiable
i'd also ask you to consider how will
this impact those industries and
companies around the state that are
a high employee count but very low
volume i'm talking about restaurants
and food stores
and retail establishment and hotels
they uh the very nature of their type of
business requires a lot of employees
but they all
operate on very low margins so what
impact would this have on their uh
taxes and and their costs to run a
business in new hampshire so mr chair i
could probably go on but i don't want to
monopolize all the time i know there are
others here to speak on the bill i would
be happy to answer any questions
thank you mr gervais questions from the
committee
representative
chamber
thank you for taking my question mr
duvet
does the wage paid by a business affect
the
uh
i would suggest that it has an impact
but not the only impact and and i'll use
the times we are operating in now as an
example
i was recently in uh house labor
committee where a similar question came
up and my response to the committee
was i receive calls almost daily from
our members who are struggling to find
employees and they're asking a simple
question
what are other employers paying right
now and um
and the answer is everyone's paying more
and that's what it's taking to
to attract people into the the workplace
so
um you know
like representative mcguire i don't want
to you know get into a discussion of the
minimum wage but but when those
discussions come up what we quickly find
out is most uh employers around the
state even those that you would think of
as being generally lower wage employers
like fast food restaurants
are either paying 15 an hour sometimes
higher to get individuals in to work
there
further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
the next is greg moore from the american
for prosperity in new hampshire
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee certainly appreciate the
opportunity to be before the house ways
and means committee uh for the record my
name is greg moore i am the state
director with americans for prosperity
and and we oppose house bill 1478 for a
number of reasons the first of which was
obviously brought up by representative
lang representative primary
representative alame which of course um
our constitution requires that our taxes
be uniformly applied and broadly based i
don't know how you can argue that this
is uniformly applied when there creates
three categories of employers one
category being
business
businesses that pay 15 as well as as the
prior speaker mentioned
nonprofits that don't pay business
profits tax
businesses that don't pay 15 an hour
that are greater than 100 and then
businesses that don't pay 15 that are
under 100 so there's three different
groups of
classes of taxpayers that are not
treated equally that's the first issue
the second issue
of course is the issue of
creating these additional deformities to
the tax code we certainly oppose the
idea of of adding more of these uh as
committee might remember we certainly
we're not fans of the of the army tax
exemption we don't support continued
expansion of the
research and development tax credit
we believe that the better strategy are
low rates for all and not having
government government do anything to
pick winners and pick winners and losers
and and this this bill does pick winners
and losers um
third one's more of uh just just as
someone who used to work with the house
uh just advise this committee don't do
this to yourself
don't allow
work from other committees to start
working its way into this committee
and just push back and make sure it
stays in the committee it belongs and
this is a labor issue and should belong
in the labor committee as a prior
speaker mentioned
and i think that's a an important
consideration for the long-term workload
of this committee you guys have enough
on your plate as it is now
and then and and then uh just
fundamentally uh obviously we oppose tax
increases and this bill is would be a
tax increase we believe that there's
been tremendous success in
the work the state has done over the
course of the last uh seven years or so
as it relates to uh tax policy with the
bet and bbt we think that's been very
successful and we think going in the
opposite direction is a bad idea so with
that those are our reasons for opposing
1478 and i'd be glad to take any
questions from the committee
thanks for your testimony mr moore
seeing none thank you thank you
the next is
curtis berry representing the new
hampshire retail association
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee
my name is curtis barry here
representing the new hampshire retail
association which as you know represents
several hundred businesses across the
state ranging from major national chains
to
smaller main street shops in opposition
to this bill
um
we start by saying i think uh i would
agree on behalf of the retailers with
everything mr zhuvay said but i'd like
to give you a retail specific spin on it
if you will and sort of categorize my
testimony in the same two areas um first
of all i think you're all aware that
retail is a very seasonal business there
are times of the year depending on what
the type of retailer is they're much
busier than than other times curtis can
you move your sorry closer sure
how's that
great
um and because of that
seasonal nature
many times retailers will hire folks
that not only are school students high
school and college but also retired
folks looking to pick up a little extra
money
could be a flower shop around mother's
day
in
they may accept a wage because it's good
work for them
that's a little lower than what they pay
everybody else in in representative
schoenberg i would like to answer your
question as well at the end of this i
think to provide some context
um
and this bill has the
would have the impact perhaps of denying
somebody that opportunity because it
would drive a higher tax rate
as mr zhuvay said it could be a
shop of 100 or more people and one
person
is hired on a part-time basis to answer
some phones as a busy time to take
orders and it could be 12 bucks an hour
but it's they want to pick up a little
extra spending money which would deny
them this opportunity because it kicks
the business into a higher tax rate
this bill does not contemplate i don't
think retail employees who work on a
commission basis their hourly rate may
be lower but they make pretty good money
because the rest is made up of
commissions so there's a lot of
specifics in the retail industry that
to
[Music]
mirror what you've heard before from
representative mcguire mr jouve
i hope we would all agree
that the tax code is not there for
punitive measures to punish an employer
because they engage in a business
practice that we don't like
once you start down this road it has
literally no end
um and then to provide the context and i
think address representative schomburg's
question i will give you a real
life example that i just an hour ago
gave to the house labor committee
i'm aware of a particular
major retailer
with a store in the southern part of the
state
that in trying to hire for the holiday
season back in the fall
found themselves 45 positions short for
the holiday season one single location
45 positions short of what they would
consider optimal
in addition
they hired 30 people
signed them up ready to go
who never showed up to work
didn't call didn't give any notice
didn't show up
this is on top of incentives for example
several hundred dollars for finishing
out the holiday season
added uh hourly wage to work weekend
shifts and they're not finding uh the
employees they're so employers are
facing these pressures
all around
mr chairman i'm happy to answer
questions as best i can
thank you for your testimony mr barry
questions from the committee
saying none thank you thank you oops
sorry representative
thank you i just wanted to ask
on whether it would cost considerably
more for these
businesses that are hiring seasonally
part-time we're talking about an hourly
wage
and so
giving them another three dollars an
hour for that period would probably be a
lot cheaper than
i don't know than the raise in since
they're on such a low margin it might
not
thank you for that question and it's a
question again that comes up not
infrequently upstairs in the labor
committee on similar issues
um
and i hope we all recognize that not
only is it low margin in the retail
business but it's very price sensitive
so i think retailers
whether it be store manager for a larger
one store owner for a smaller one
understands their market and understands
that balance because
uh when a consumer is making a decision
to purchase product
it could be a decision between product a
and product b
um i'll go back to my flower shop
arrangement it could be
if the price were a little lower they
would pick the larger arrangement which
maybe has a bigger profit margin and if
the price is a little higher they're
going to pick the smaller one but
consumers also make decisions between
product a and not no product at all i
can't afford this at a higher rate so
i think folks on the ground that are in
this situation living the business day
to day are in the best position to make
any further questions
send none question mr chairman i'm sorry
for being so small
thank you mr chairman
so are you saying then that
higher wages
are the cause for
a product not being on shelves and
things like that
um
mr chairman
feel free to cut me off anytime so i
think we're getting a little bit off
topic but i'd like to to respond to that
um not not the sole weight not the sole
reason
i guess what i was suggesting
representative
is that any additional cost
that retailers experience
will have an impact one way or another
it will be either higher prices
or it will be a lower margin for the
retailer or it will be
fewer hours that they hire somebody to
pay for
in the example i wish to give you again
i gave this this is a real life example
i just gave to the labor committee
furniture stores are now telling us
telling their customers you order a
but the impact that that weight is
solely on the story if you put a deposit
down on a piece of furniture
it's at a certain price uh 12 months
later shipping costs in particular
nowadays have increased and that's
driven by the container costs coming in
from overseas which have doubled or
tripled uh it's the hourly rate that the
the trucker is
getting at this point
but the store cannot pass that along to
that consumer in that particular
circumstance the customer has agreed to
buy a piece of furniture at a particular
price
so there's two choices either the
customer cancels which is in nobody's
best interest
uh or the store eats the increase in
cost over over that 12 months having
accepted a deposit for a piece of
furniture at a certain price it is not
easy to be in the retail business these
days
any further questions and none thank you
for your testimony thank you sir
and the last card is
drew
klein uh representing josiah bartlett
thank you mr chairman uh and committee
i'll be brief because everybody else
stole my thunder and made all the points
i was going to make about
constitutionality and and use of the tax
code um but i just wanted to suggest um
i think uh
you know a former representative
suggests the title is
uh maybe inaccurate and i would maybe
offer a different title for it um
something like
the entry-level job elimination act
or um
or the or the electronic kiosk full
employment act
um because what this would do
uh
i think the foundational
misunderstanding is that not aside from
the constitutionality and the use of the
tax code is that uh misunderstanding
what a job is a job is an exchange of
compensation for services rendered and a
job is not
does not exist not every job exists
to support a whole family so
whether you even if you have over 100
employees i mean there are manufacturers
based in new hampshire there are
companies based in new hampshire that
aren't amazon and target and et cetera
they have more than 100 employees and
maybe they are paying entry-level wages
at 13 14 an hour
and this would punish them for that and
uh and it would discourage them from
offering those entry-level jobs to get
people up to speed i mean
we hear from employers all the time that
they pay a lower wage for entry level
because that person has less experience
and then as that person gains experience
and becomes therefore more valuable to
the employer the wages go up
um and right now you can see what
happens in an economy when
um
the pressure on wages is so great that
the
those entry-level jobs become
uneconomical for the employer so if you
go to any mcdonald's you'll see the
kiosks up um i would suggest that this
would
expand that
greatly so and it's not you know again
we we think of this often in terms of
the large mega corporation that's super
rich but
um the bill says over 100 employees not
over 100 employees in new hampshire
so
there are other industries that this
would affect that operate on low margins
that aren't necessarily big wealthy
corporations and i'll just throw out one
um that's been really affected by the
pandemic is movie theaters so a lot of
the there are some independent movie
theaters in new hampshire but there are
some movie theaters in new hampshire
that are part of large
um out-of-state companies and movie
theater i i my first job as a movie
theater i love it i love movie theaters
they pay lower wages generally because
it's very low skilled to take tickets
and to get somebody a soda um
they are already transitioning to
primarily kiosks and um i think this
would make the customer experience worse
by forcing them to pay 15 an hour for a
job that
is not necessarily worth that to them
but that they can then
uh replace with an electronic
interaction for the customer so i just
think there are lots of unintended
consequences here that committee ought
to be aware of and that's all
thank you for your testimony questions
from the committee
representative
representative camaro speaking in
thank you mr chair um as a co-sponsor i
i wasn't going to say much but i i
signed on because i thought this was a
topic that needed to be discussed and
as it turns out we've had more pink
cards for this bill than any other
as a business owner
i'd like to give a little bit of my
perspective
i married into a family business
established in 1939
it was a grocery store at first and then
my husband expanded it some
we sold
the grocery business in
and we've kept the gas station
and i've had three workers that i've
paid over 15 an hour since then
and i just want you to know that it can
be done
and we don't need billionaires
people just need to take care of their
own like they used to
and so that's my testimony and i'll take
any questions
okay thank you for your testimony
representative
does the dra want to
good morning committee members my name
is king manuel uh deary
um
move the mic closer to you
can you hear me now
okay better um in terms of the
constitution
constitutionality issue
according to our fiscal notes we have
not done a review on the on that
particular issue so um
we can't really comment on that but
hearing what uh representative army was
saying earlier
um
the the floor for the bpt or the bet
in my perspective i don't think it
creates separate classes of taxpayers
and therefore um
it's not a constitutional issue
but this one um
from
from what i read it looks like it is
creating
um
separate classes so it could be a
potential issue but once again um we
have not done that particular analysis
so i would hesitate to comment further
questions
anybody else wish to testify for or
uh paul would you check to see if there
are any
okay
i
see nobody else wishing to testify for
or against house bill 1478
i'm closing the public hearing on 1478
and with the dra just put in a pink card
thank you
and we will meet back here at one
o'clock
i'll
take care of 14.98
i'm going to open the public hearing on
house bill 1494
an act relative to property tax
exemptions concerning certain
communication services leases
the primary uh the prime sponsor
representative rose is here to introduce
thank you chairman major and good
afternoon ex distinguished colleagues of
the ways and means committee i'm happy
to be here
for the record i am representative
michael boze i represent rockingham
district 9 the town of epping
and i serve as chair of the
house science technology and energy
committee and this morning i'm here for
this afternoon actually i'm here to
introduce house bill 14
94.
quick introduction this is a tax cut
bill
longer introduction
so
for many many years earlier in my life i
used to hike extensively in the white
mountains
and
with my hiking buddies we would often
discuss
reports that we had seen about
hiking expeditions that had gone wrong
accidents that had happened people had
gotten hurt etcetera now we always used
to
question
what happened
what mistake did they make that led to
that accident
and what we learned over time is that
accidents don't typically happen because
of one cause sometimes they do but not
typically usually it's an
accumulation of small mistakes
that lead to a bad outcome
well the same can be true in reverse
and an accumulation of small
and that's why i introduced house bill
1494 it's a small bill
the tax cut that it proposes
is modest two and a half maybe to maybe
three and a half million dollars a year
but that additional
money
could have a big impact
and the reason for that is because
during the pandemic of course we learned
that broadband internet is vital
to our state to the citizens of our
state it enables remote learning it
enables
and we've worked hard over the course of
the last 10 15 years to expand broadband
in our state and we're we're pretty
close about 95 percent of the people in
in our state have decent broadband
service
getting to that
last five percent
what's frequently returned to referred
to as the last mile
is difficult and expensive
so everything we can do
to
get a step closer
to solving the last mile problem
is
one of the ways we can get there is to
reduce the costs of expanding broadband
infrastructure and that's the small step
that this legislation will take
by reducing taxes
on broadband
suppliers
by a modest amount that they can then
turn around and invest in broadband
expansion
this is a high priority for
a lot of people in our state i served in
my third term my second term i'm sorry
on a broadband study committee and
we looked at this issue for
months
and discovered that it's a very tough
issue to solve
and there had been previous broadband
study committees which also had looked
at this issue and not come up with any
easy solutions either
but we've got to solve this problem it's
a high priority for the business and
industry
association for example they recognize
the critical role of telecommunications
and high-speed internet
and fostering a healthy growing economy
across new hampshire
and they support efforts it's a
legislative
priority for the bia
to support efforts to expand private
sector telecommunications infrastructure
throughout the state
to improve access quality and
reliability
so how will this bill contribute to that
there are people who will testify after
me that will give you a more detailed
and nuanced explanation for how it works
but i'll give you a broad overview the
bill simply adds an exception an
exemption
similar to exemptions that already exist
from a property tax on the use of
way now broadband vendors today often
pay tax twice
on using these
rights of way because they pay property
tax on the polls and conduits
the the hardware infrastructure but they
also pay again
to use the right-of-way
this exemption would
reduce
or exempt them from paying the polls and
exemptions like this one are already
provided to to charitable organizations
to agricultural agriculture uses as well
as state-owned railroad property so this
is not a unique exemption this is just
an exempt an extension of an exemption
that already exists
and what this bill will do it will level
the playing field for
vendors
and it'll reduce the fixed costs of
deploying broadband infrastructure
this bill will also go along with the
theme
of the
governor sununu administration that
started uh in 2021
of reducing taxes that was a
broad theme of his administration for
the biennium that we're currently in and
this continues that tradition
of reducing taxes
in a responsible and reasonable way
that
in the long term
will help our st our citizens statewide
another small benefit that might result
from this bill is
some of the
vendors who would benefit from this bill
actually provide landline telephone
service
and they actually list on their bills a
right-of-way charge
and they could reduce that charge if
this bill were to pass won't affect cell
phones but would affect landline phones
as i said
a few minutes ago there are folks who
are going to testify behind me who
can give you more details
but that's the broad overview of what
this bill does and i'm happy to
introduce it and also happy to take
questions thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative
questions from the committee
representative schomburg
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative
is this a loss of revenue for towns and
an increase in a town's tax rate to
overcome
this loss of revenue
yes this would be a small loss of
revenue to municipalities
estimated to be about two and a half to
three and a half million statewide so
per municipality it would be a
relatively small number
follow up mr chairman follow up
[Music]
you stated by reducing the taxes on
broadband suppliers
have the broadband suppliers or vendors
made a commitment to finish the last
mile
there will be representatives of
broadband companies testifying after me
you could ask them that question
uh in general i think they have made
that commitment but we're getting there
the details of getting there
are
what we're here to address today thank
you
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh
my my question is
you're you're saying this is a
two and a half million dollar tax cut
fine
and this would be
this supposedly this money be used for
expanding or
hopefully expanding broadband
and we have what you said five percent
of the
state
still
is in need of that what is that dollar
amount needed to to fulfill that and
expand that to do the last mile as
you've
indicated
that's a good question maybe one of the
broadband
folks who testify later could answer
that
further question representative lyon
thank you mr chair thank you
representatives for taking my question i
i just want to be clear on the 2 million
dollars we're talking about is that part
of the state upt
or is that the local property tax loss
that you think is going to happen
these are municipal taxes thank you
further questions represent elmi
thank you mr chairman it's on the five
percent that
do not yet have broadband is that
calculated from census tracts or from
household survey
yes from
my recollection of serving on the
broadband study committee that i served
on
i believe the answer to your question is
a census
i'd have to go look it up to be sure
though
thank you it does make an enormous
difference
the next is a chris hodgson
from comcast
[Music]
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is chris hodgston i'm
comcast vice president of government
affairs here in new hampshire
and my testimony is being distributed
now it touches on half dozen or so
policy reasons why we support this
legislation
but i wanted to just
the
first and foremost the imperative
associated with trying to push out
broadband to
areas of the state that are unserved and
there's a
can be a question about how the ultimate
number is arrived at the fcc
says that it's somewhere in the 97 98
range
challenges with the granularity of any
data especially when you're collecting
it at a statewide basis so
i i have long said and i think it to be
true that a more
realistic estimate is about 95 percent
um that said that fcc data is based on
census blocks not tracks blocks of
course are the smaller of the two
geographic polygons but nonetheless
we're in that range at this point
what makes this
legislation i think particularly useful
for broadband providers is that
remaining five percent does not
constitute five percent of the land area
in the state doesn't constitute five
percent of the miles that we're going to
have to wire
to serve those remaining people
in fact there are
i think by any reasonable estimate
hundreds and hundreds perhaps a thousand
or more miles
of road
mostly public some private
that are going to need to be built to
get that last five percent
and
fixed costs like attacks are
particularly meaningful when broadband
providers are trying to determine
whether or not they can justify building
their network because
every year we have to account for that
cost and
there are many cost variable capital
fixed costs associated with broadband
networks we can't solve all of those
challenges
this piece of legislation seeks to
address one of them and just to give you
a sense of what that means
a mile of infrastructure in a rural part
of the state may have
four or five possible customers
even the very best adoption programs
uh can only get to maybe a penetration
of 70
you never get everyone for a host of
reasons
to to subscribe
um that mile of infrastructure
for us
has fixed costs that include
the rent that we pay to reside on the
polls
35 polls a mile
anywhere between 10 and 15 dollars a
poll per year
and then the tax is associated with it
it's not hard to see why
higher fixed costs make it very
difficult to justify expansion
so that's our primary the primary policy
justification for taking a hard look at
this change
the other
issue this is specific of course the
cable industry is that we already fully
compensate municipalities for the use of
there right away the federal government
provides a statutory framework that
requires us to give permission to
operate in towns right away it's called
a franchise in return for that franchise
we
municipalities can charge up to five
percent of our gross video revenue as a
franchise fee
in new hampshire that constitutes an r
footprint a little over 13 million
dollars a year and in many many
situations that
federal construct which is applied
locally has been determined to fully
compensate municipalities for the use of
their right of way
and this
local this tax which is unique and i
want to just make sure that the
committee understands
we're not talking about an exemption for
taxation on real property
this is a tax levied on the use and
occupation of our personal property in
the right of way it's our wire to
network infrastructure that we're
talking about that's having a tax
applied to it
and then new hampshire is nearly unique
in the united states in the use of
attacks like this only california
taxes use and occupation of their rights
away and they tax the use and occupation
of real property in the right of way not
personal property
so
for the reasons that i've outlined in my
testimony
and
written testimony what i've described
here today before you
we we support this legislation it is not
this is certainly obvious to
i think everyone on the committee and in
the room
this is not a panacea for
the states or any state's broadband
problem
this is
a statutory change that will change the
calculus for how
we have to account for our fixed costs
we've determined whether or not we can
deploy a network
there's a lot of parts that go into that
but this would certainly uh help
thank you for your time i understand
it's limited and i'd be happy to take
enter any questions you may have yeah
i'll start um
first i apologize for being late i had
to
introduce another bill
can you just recapitulate for me this
we're talking about as the right of way
and you say it's unique right away
compared to other states can you just
embellish a little bit on that sure so
describes
how in a situation when there's a an
agreement or lease
to
use that right away the tax the
municipality or the state
can levy attacks
and it's a fairly lengthy statute but
that's the the basis of it
um it's not 728 which is the part of the
statute that deals with real property
taxation
it's for
an instance where
personal property or
real property is
is occupying or using
land owned by the state or one of its
subdivisions and
and what it would do
similar to the way the
exemption exists for leases relative to
state-owned railways
the language and the bill would
essentially say that if you
are
if you have personal property or
property in the right-of-way
that generates revenue for local
municipalities
through some other provision of state
law so perhaps it's 72 8 which is
related to real property taxation it
could be 53 c which is the statute that
relates to our franchise with to occupy
and use it right away which is the
source of that 13 million dollars in
revenue that we collect and remit to
municipalities that's that's what we're
talking about here
okay does that answer your question yes
thank you um
and representative ames
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh the same same question that i asked
before do you have a number of what it
would cost to
make that last mile connection here in
new hampshire
i can't
i can't offer one
that is
i can't offer a detailed estimate
um we know
we're in the process now uh because of
uh
the imperative created obviously by this
pandemic
to to scope that out and it is it's a
very substantial amount i mean if you
consider
average costs of
40 50
plus thousand dollars a mile to deploy
infrastructure
a thousand
miles of road if if that is what it'll
take to push this out to the final five
percent is in the tens of millions of
dollars
it's uh it's a large undertaking which
is
frankly why it hasn't been taken to date
it's very expensive to do it when there
are very few if any customers to
good afternoon
um
so i actually have two questions uh
first is uh
is related to
the question of
the question is whether some of those
last miles
are
concentrated
in some parts or some municipalities
or is it more or less evenly spread
so based on what i've seen in the
analysis we've done there's
a modest range
between
less than half a dozen homes a mile to
less than 10 homes a mile in these areas
that are unserved
new hampshire
i don't i don't need to
tell you the history of how new
hampshire developed but by and large we
developed
as a series of
village centers centered around some
sort of industry typically a water
supply of some sort had to be part of
that and as a consequence
there are pockets of relatively high
density
and then many areas of very low density
and even
a few hundred years after that initial
development that holds true in many
parts of the state we see
village centers with 100 150 200
locations that are serviceable which is
how we think about it homes businesses
government facilities and then
long stretches
where there's
very little development
and then there are other
issues that interrelate with that land
use considerations how we've chosen to
develop with larger lots
buildings are set back from roads these
things all contribute to
the challenges we experience when we
do you have maps or data that might
be in sufficient summary form that would
enable us to look at that question of
differential impact so i will uh i will
send to the entire committee a link to
the most recent
federal mapping data which is
a work in progress
but it's going to give you the most
complete view of what we're looking at
in the state okay that would be helpful
then i have a follow-up question
and
this is the question
as i understand it
this
exemption
would apply to two categories i would
identify one would be
existing personal property out there
that's
now subject to the tax
and the other would be
to be developed last mile whatever you
want to call it
property
and we've heard from the previous
uh
testimony
that
part of the reason for this bill is a
tax cut
bill and that the tax cut the savings
would be about
between two and three million dollars
that's what i remember
and
i'd like to know what part of that
if you can help us on this uh
is
taxes that are now being paid
versus
taxes that might be paid if you manage
to pull this off and
go further down that last mile
so if i understand your question
correctly
i'll answer it this way so
the
half a million or so homes that we serve
right now in the state
not all our customers but we in 112
communities we serve we pass about 100
about 500 000 locations
all of them through a wired network so
all of
that right away is subject to
the areas that we don't serve we haven't
built infrastructure in not right away
we're not the only provider that's
seeking to accomplish this work we're
not gonna i'm sorry i said we're not the
only provider seeking to solve this
problem there are
providers who have network
infrastructure in the right of way
traditional telephone companies
whose network infrastructure does not
provide broadband service so there they
are already occupying it with their
infrastructure it's being utilized for
phone or
services that aren't
necessarily considered broadband speeds
so that would
they would already be paying
use and occupation tax on it
already so
and one of the if you look at my
testimony one of the
rationales behind this addressing this
issue is that not all providers are
being treated the same
there's a supreme court case in 2017
where
another type of provider
what's known as a clek
sued the city of nashua over whether or
not that was this application of the tax
to them was lawful and the court said no
because unlike us or a phone company
that type of provider doesn't have an
agreement or license from the city so no
license to be there
no
nexus that allows the taxation
the net result of that is that provider
who's sitting on exactly the same polls
that we are
running wires a foot or uh above us or
below us is not paying this tax and we
are so there's a
you know to the extent there's a desire
to have competitive equity among like
providers this is a real challenge with
this statute and that's one of the
rationales for for fixing it
good question about a fiscal note is
there
i don't see one here is there do you
know anything about that because
we clearly would be helped by
some analysis of this question all right
we'll make sure we'll take a look at
that
well first my prior
question
which was
about the um
whether we were using census tracts or
surveys to get to the 95 percent it
sounded like you said census tracts
uh no census blocks so yes center sparks
so census tracts are
areas that have perhaps two to three
thousand locations in them census blocks
of which there are roughly 70 thousand
in new hampshire have
15 to 18
locations in them so it's far far more
granular
the
the fcc is going through a transition
away from census blocks to
um what are known as like polygon maps
right so
the map boundaries the serviceability
boundaries will be defined not by a
somewhat arbitrary
shape which is a census block
set by a government agency doesn't
relate to
telecom network footprint at all
to data collection that is more based on
the physical ability of these networks
to reach a certain location
and
because of that they're going to be more
accurate
that's going on right now
at the fcc it was a function of
first
dollars appropriated through cares
and then more recently
either through infrastructure or arpa i
don't recall which of the two
bills funded that effort but it's it's
appropriated
we know what the pathway is to these
maps and uh
that's going on right now so but it's
census blocks which are
smaller geographic areas
thank you if i could have a follow-up
yes please
on
that
i don't know how they'd do a census
block in my small complex which is 22
units
but
they um
that won't be ready i guess for a few
years
so we won't
the
the problem is there are two problems
here one of them is getting the cable
there and the other one is the people in
a house being able to afford to pay your
prices
which i am a comcast customer
i haven't managed to get it down below
what i was paying in new york city for a
single apartment 40 years ago
yet
but
uh
the
the question
that
i've got is where
if this was passed and you had
two and a half to three million dollars
a year more of taxpayer money that came
from the municipalities which is our
to
to work with
would your priorities be
be actually trying to do the
least cost efficient
part of your work which is getting out
that last mile or
would you be
trying to
prove the service on your menus for
instance
so a couple points one we would not be
difference between what's taxed now and
what's what the future would hold we're
we would receive a far smaller less than
our so you know we extend the network to
areas that we haven't otherwise served
every day we extended it to 4
200 or so
brand new locations in 21
that's
a little bit less than our typical
for many obvious reasons but that's it's
always an imperative to try to figure
out where you can what new customers you
can reach
and that 4200 does not include
a major build in laconia and guilford
which is 13 plus thousand locations
that's just
uh extensions beyond where we already
are in the other hundred and ten or so
towns
um including i'm sure every town that
that you all represent
uh so it's
it is
it would
design projects
in a way that we just currently can't do
in terms of taking into account our
fixed cost
that's the best way to describe it it's
impossible to point to
you know a particular project or stretch
of road that would now be feasible that
isn't or would
would be feasible and now isn't i should
say but
it is it's part of that puzzle and when
we look at
that formula here
relative to other places this is one of
all but a small piece
of the puzzle that's different here that
that we don't have to account for
elsewhere
okay
representative lange
thank you and and my question is around
the same conversation you said wherever
i said it's all me thank you for taking
my question thank you mr chair
so
in my past life i was actually director
for hampshire electric car but one of
the important things i learned is that
up in north country they average seven
subscribers per mile as compared to
manchester united as 70 subscribers per
mile so you can understand the business
model
challenges of extending out that extra
mile for seven subscribers and how
you're going to get the return on that
and i guess my question is if we're
if to represent almi's point is there
going to be a relationship between the
tax break we give you and the expansion
of the program and i mean i think that's
a huge you know the talking point for
what we're here is we're going to give
you a tax break and the idea is to
expand the program is that i don't want
to come back next year and see 4 200 you
know the same expansion rate that you
were doing before and we gave you a 2.3
million tax break over across the whole
state so my question is what's the
correlational relationship between the
tax break and the expansion of the
network and is there any commitment to
there is
there's absolutely a correlation between
our
cost analysis for a project the reality
of that project that you described and
whether or not we can do it
absolutely
this is
this is by no means
the largest input into that formula it's
just not we're talking about
you know
perhaps two and a half three million
dollars over a very large
geographic area relatively speaking so i
don't want to i don't want to oversell
it as as a solution to our challenges
it's it is part of the solution
it is
a fixed cost that we have to account for
here and factor in that we wouldn't we
don't otherwise
and that has an impact uh it's it's just
simply
given the scale of the solution
that's represented by this piece of
legislation
it's probably not possible to show you
the discrete areas of the state that all
of a sudden become economically feasible
it's
i'd love to be able to do it if the
numbers were bigger it'd be easier to do
it
uh that doesn't make them less
meaningful they're just not
they're just not as big
representative schaumburg
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh
did comcast
not yet
we we received from the state of new
hampshire
and to help build out three locations
in canaan loudon and hinsdale the summer
of 2020.
that was new hampshire's connecting
new hampshire
broadband program it was a cares act
funded program
those
three projects constituted just under
100 homes
in those three towns
we are
awaiting the release of the state's arpa
funded
program you may recall that last year
the legislature created a broadband
match and grant program it's housed at
bea
we are we're waiting to see
the source of the funds to to make that
program
work will be arpa the capital projects
fund money so we're waiting to see what
that looks like
i'm hopeful that we can
mr chairman just quick follow
how much money did you receive on the
from new hampshire
it was
estimated
one of the challenges was it had to be
100 done by december 15th
there's a program that got announced in
august
i would have liked to have done a lot
more but it was not possible at that
point
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my next question
here and it has to do with uh
specifics on the money
and
i apologize if this is um
maybe
an unfair question but i
i want to i want to understand that the
two and a half million that could be
saved by the uh
by eliminating this tax
that is then if i
that is then split
among the various providers so they
wouldn't all
be
captured by comcast absolutely right
follow-up
in your estimation what percentage of
that money would go to comcast less than
any other questions and that's just
that's based on what we know to be our
tax bills now it's yeah
and uh
you know the two and a half to three and
a half million is very much an estimate
it's purely an estimate based on what we
know the size of our network to be what
we know our current tax bill to be and
what we believe to be
the presence of other providers networks
it's it's very much an effort at
ballparking
um let me ask you
is your network all fiber
the backbone of its fiber it's a hybrid
network the back one is 100
yes fiber
the network architecture is
fiber to the node the node is a
electronic device within
a few hundred feet of a customer's home
that transfers light
spectrum into rf
rf travels over
coaxial cable right the last few hundred
feet it's
what would i remember there was a bill
years ago about about this and what is
it per mile to to pull at that cable
well up to
there's no so aerial deployment
obviously underground is dramatically
more expensive aerial deployment
000 plus in the variable variability
might be
25 that's based on
make ready you know what it takes us to
make the polls
sound for our arrival on them our
attachment to them there's
uh so
but you you least
you don't you don't put polls in
it's it's really that you you're in
space on the on telephone poles or
electric poles the vast majority of our
network is attached to poles owned by
some combination of an electric company
and a phone company
we do set
infrequently but when we need to we set
our own polls typically our goal there
is to turn an ownership over to the
incumbent electric or phone provider app
right after we do it
they're in the business of poll
maintenance we're
we're not we're in the business of
paying them to be on their polls so
last question that
so
the the
taxing that's going on it affects cable
companies but i would assume telephone
companies does it impact the electric
companies as well does not just the
telecoms and the uh
thank you mr chair
when you wire a community
are you aware of uh
or can you quantify the impact on
housing
on property values
where i'm going with this is
the gross number is two two and a half
million of revenue that will be foregone
but if it increases property values some
of that can be recaptured in property
taxes yeah i i have seen a lot of um
rhetorical and anecdotal commentary on
that i've never we've never been the
source of an analysis of that but you
routinely see real estate agents
say that it can impact the property
value by you know 10 or more 20
i have i do not know the source of that
data
but you routinely hear that from folks
that are experts in the housing industry
i i don't know how that's viewed
in terms of assessment methodology by
very frequently hear that as a
result of broadband deployments
okay i appreciate the response thank you
any other questions
i see none thank you very much
appreciate it thank you thank you for
your time today and i'm available to
answer any other questions if they come
up
well now we're going to hear a little
bit about telecom as well here uh
maureen weston
from sports to sports to bill from the
new england cable and telecommunications
association
good afternoon members of the committee
um can you hear me
all right yep great thank you
my name is maura weston i appreciate the
opportunity to be here today
on behalf of the new england cable and
telecommunications association
our members including atlantic broadband
charter
and comcast are new hampshire's leading
broadband
and communications providers
with approximately 485 000 customers
in more than 184 communities in the
state
excuse me we testify in support of this
bill today because we believe
it encourages investment in broadband
infrastructure
and deployment in a competitively
neutral way
this legislation creates tax equity
uh you heard from mr hodgin about
franchise fees our members in new
hampshire collectively
pay franchise fees to municipalities
totaling
approximately 16 million annually
reducing tax burdens on providers in an
equitable manner will encourage
the reallocation of dollars toward
deployment
again as you heard from mr hodgson
and i'd like to take a few moments today
to share with you a little bit of
history
about telecommunications taxation in new
hampshire
i think it provides a really valuable
context
as you evaluate the merits of what's in
front of you today
the bottom line is that the tax
environment
in new hampshire has
evolved
into an environment that is not
necessarily conducive
to incentivizing broadband deployment at
this point or as in we're not as
incentivizing as it could be i should
say
so let's go back to the 70s
um
and i'll try to make this brief but
beginning in the 70s landline
companies landline telephone companies
paid a statewide tax on personal
property
such as polls and conduits that was
because the telecommunications
industry was evolving and you had
wireless entrance etc
in 1990
the cst was created
and the state decided to no longer tax
those polls and conduits as personal
property
but rather
impose a more equitable tax structure on
the service to be provided
through the cst
that tax policy correctly
awarded picking winners and losers
based upon technology in a competitive
and emerging industry
between 1990 and 1998
after that statewide property tax had
been repealed and the cst was enacted
municipalities stepped in
and started taxing the telephone
company's personal property
the companies filed abatements they won
and courts held
that the munis could not tax they did
not have the authority to tax personal
property
then the electric companies
filed abatements on the theory that
their polls were unfairly taxed
in order to settle the claims
in 2007
senate bill 73 was enacted and that
reclassified
the polls and conduits
as real property no longer personal
property but now real property
and at the same time there was imposed
an exemption from the real estate tax
so it was a reclassification
and an exemption imposed and now is a
court sanctioned solution
to that to those electric abatement
filings
that exemption on property taxation
was an integral part of new hampshire's
overall tax policy
created by the legislature and upheld by
the supreme court
and for many years it was viewed as
equitable and fair
competitively neutral
in 1996
um the muni's realized well
we can't tax the polls and conduit as
real property or personal property
so we're going to get a little creative
and we're going to amend the poll
license the the licenses
uh for the rights of way to include
language
from 72 23
which would require the payment of taxes
for the use and occupation of the
right-of-way so it's sort of like well
if it's not one tax or another tax it's
going to be this other tax
and
the practice
of including that language
in the leases
has continued
and we will tell you that
many know
though not all municipalities have
in 2010 interestingly
the legislature refused to pass house
bill 492
which would have
extended that exemption
uh from real property taxation on polls
and conduits that had been created in
2007.
so as of 2010
you had municipalities now taking
advantage
of the use and occupation tax
and now also have the ability
to tax
structures polls and conduit
in 2017
as as mr hodgson referenced
there was a case brought to the state
supreme court
and in that case
it was recognized that not all
competitors
had licenses to use the
right-of-way and rather could deploy
through poll attachment agreements
so this evolution of tax policy has sort
of led to a cumulative effect of more
taxes being imposed
upon entities deploying in the rights of
way
and in
and in inequity
among those competitive players
and i share all of that history with you
because i think it provides a good
context
we can look at this as a tax break or
tax cut
or we can look at it as re-establishing
tax equity
among competitive players in the
industry
so just as a reminder the cst is imposed
on telecommunications services
under 82 a
structures polls and conduits are taxed
as real property
pursuant to 72 8a
franchise fees as has been discussed
or paid to municipalities pursuant to
53c
and companies with infrastructure within
the rights of way
are taxed for use in occupation
under 72 23.
so based on this history
we see that there has traditionally been
a desire to treat all competitive
technologies fairly and with a level
playing field
and we believe that this bill is
consistent with that and so we ask for
your support
and i'm happy to answer questions to the
extent i can
okay
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
uh
being the chair of my local bos
and i see the effective date is july 1st
uh
will this exemption affect
the budgets
of my town or the other towns that are
you may not be able to i'm sorry you may
not be able to answer that i should have
asked the expert
i haven't done the math on that and and
i i don't know what the budget cycle is
or
how that would
intersect with the effective date but i
think you know that's a conversation
worth having and i think the overall
goal here is smart equitable tax policy
mr chairman
yeah i think we're going to need
by the way this was a great presentation
i really appreciate it thank you i'm
sure it took a lot of work
i hate to admit that i'm old enough to
remember much of it
so thank you
so um on the second page of your
a printed testimony there's four bullets
and the fourth bullet is i think what
we're talking about
here
um
so it gets back to an early a question i
asked earlier a previous
testifier
and it is
i'm in search of information
you say companies
are taxed for the use and occupation of
those rights of way
and what i want to know is
what those taxes are and who's paying
and what municipalities are
receiving them
i don't know whether you're the
in the best position to provide that
information i don't know who is but
we um
our industry within new hampshire the
cable industry we estimate that we're
paying
somewhere
over around a million
annually
for use in occupation
again that's just our industry and again
there's some inconsistency where some
municipalities have amended their
licenses to authorize this and others
haven't so
that's unfortunately as precise as i can
be
but we can you know dig a little deeper
and help to shine a little bit more
light
anything you can provide would be most
appreciated
okay
thank you thanks for taking my question
would you agree with mr hodgson that it
would be
we're dealing with
uh thousands
more miles
of of this to reach
uh
the remaining part of
the five percent that isn't served in
new hampshire
yes i would i would agree and i would
echo that because again our association
is not just comcast but atlantic
broadband and charter who do
serve more of the rural parts of the
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much
thank you so much i appreciate the
opportunity
okay uh next up is uh jim wheeler from
george san souci
um
pa pe
thank you mr chair
members um
my name is jim wheeler and um
i am here today
representing george e san souci
llc it's a firm that specializes
in the assessment of utility and special
use properties
and whose many
local government and county
clients will be adversely affected
by this bill
i provided a list of the estimated
impact of the bill
to our clients and you'll see that
i think there are 62
[Music]
the total impact
from our our database is just under 20
million uh evaluation so it's 20 million
dollars of valuation to those
towns
and obviously these are your constituent
a tax exemption on cable and
telecommunications
we feel is a subsidy that's paid for by
other taxpayers
so that two to three million dollars
that's that's being talked about um
i think i think we all realize that a
tax cut is a tax shift there's a fixed
pie if you will and a municipal budget
and if that revenue comes out
on one side of the pie it's got to go in
on the other side
usually that is made up by the other
taxpayers or is essentially always made
so you know given that we don't believe
that there's a reasonable basis for
exempting
these companies particularly when
there's adequate competition
i'd also point out that
the public right-of-way has to be
maintained
and it's maintained for all users of the
right-of-way and that includes cable and
telecommunication companies
and that they should not be exempted
from paying their share of
revenue that
not my written comments but as i was
driving down here
i was i was thinking about my my past
life as a city manager
and how
our legal counsel whenever we
entered a lease with a private party for
use of municipal property so let's say
it was a
uh a building in the industrial park
or it could have been you know even an
empty office at city hall if we wanted
to lease that space out to a
current taxation law requires that we
collect
property tax from them
so to me that is an entirely
analogous situation so
a municipality wants to rent space to a
small
business
it seems that this is again you know a
very very similar situation and that
to give them a tax break
so
in closing
we'd ask that if the bill does go
forward
at all
that it be studied in committee in a
full public process
so that it could be understood what what
the real impact and intent is
otherwise we'd ask that you vote the
rep representative ames and then
representative army yeah
thank you for this
uh is this these are your clients
yes susie
clients and uh so there's a bigger list
somewhere is that right
this is just what you've been dealing
with correct these are just san souci
clients obviously this is the only
information that that we have well it's
much appreciated
representative
sorry i had the same question because i
didn't know who was now assessing
in lebanon because we got rid of our
assessors much to my
disbelief
so are you all set then yeah okay
uh
i have no questions any anyone else okay
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
and we have one final pink card and that
is uh
catherine heck
from the new hampshire
good afternoon members of the committee
mr chairman my name is catherine heck
from the new hampshire municipal
association
um i'm here to testify today in
opposition to house bill 1494
um this legislation would exempt the
telecommunication companies as we've
heard in previous testimony from paying
their property taxes that would
otherwise be payable under the rsa 7233
um for that for the use of government
owned property
if allowed to take effect you've already
heard testimony to the effect that this
would result in a reduction in property
taxes paid by private industry
and in turn they would have to be made
up for on the municipal side on the back
of the local property tax payer
in addition
we wonder if any reduction would result
in a decrease in any user fees as most
businesses use the model of charging
based on their costs so whatever their
costs are is how they pass that along to
the consumer
furthermore i've heard about the double
tax so to make that argument our
taxpayers would also then be paying a
double tax by subsidizing the not paying
of the right-of-way in addition to
paying their property taxes
or if you look at a restaurant they're
required to pay a property tax if they
lease or own a building and they work
that into their costs but they're also
have to pass along the meals in rooms
charge which is an additional tax so i
guess we could look at that
on either side of this equation people
could be double taxed
but finally i would like to talk about
the broadband piece which is a huge
important piece to new hampshire
and
because i work in the role of helping
municipalities administer federal funds
and most recently the arpa funds and the
cares act funds i've become very
familiar with broadband funding in new
hampshire
and as previous testimony stated the
capital fund just brought in 22 million
dollars for broadband projects for
middle and last mile that has not been
fully deployed yet they are still
working on the grant eligibility
criteria those would be competitive
grants most likely for municipalities to
apply for there's a hundred million
dollars in the infrastructure fund
specifically earmarked for new hampshire
to move forward with broadband projects
2.4 million dollars was deployed so
students could connect from their home
to
a local provider that was another
arpa project that was
not anything to do with the local monies
that towns received and local towns are
using some of their arpa funds also to
move forward with broadband projects in
addition
the infrastructure project granted
northern borders the regional commission
that represents belknap carroll cheshire
coast grafton and sullivan counties an
additional
allocation of funds because the northern
part of our state is underserved in that
area specifically and in 2021 they have
awarded hebron a grant in the amount of
995 thousand dollars to do a 25 mile
fiber optic build out and the total cost
of that project to put it in perspective
was 1.8 million
they awarded sandwich with 840 000 in
federal funds to provide access to all
users every household in the town that
total project was 3.5 million
and just last year i had the opportunity
to work with my own small town in
southern new hampshire at greenfield of
1700 to do a public-private partnership
under the chesterfield model and work
with a internet provider to bring
broadband to every single household we
bonded that project and that will be
paid through user fees so
there are these wonderful opportunities
right now to bring broadband especially
given the amount of federal dollars
coming into our state and we would urge
you to vote
an expedient to legislate as we believe
this would um affect our our local
taxpayers
and budgets
any questions any questions uh
representative malloy
thank you thank you uh
mr chairman
thank you for taking my question in your
opinion
is this the place where these tens of
millions of dollars could be
used to build out the last mile of
broadband in new hampshire yes it's
actually
specified in the federal legislation it
is to be used for that purpose to get
representative before you go
so how many dollars were available for
that
um
well i believe it's close to 200 million
over the next four years is my
understanding thank you representative
army
uh
i don't know how many people
read the letter that came in last night
on our email from
margaret burns
the
municipal association executive director
but
in her last paragraph
she claims that on the basis of the 2007
supreme court decision new hampshire
supreme court decision
that it is unconstitutional to subject
certain entities in that case to a
telephone company to taxation under rsa
72 23 1b
while not taxing other entities gas
cable and electric companies that use
the public property in the same manner
and claims that
hb 1494
does exactly that and that it would be
declared invalidated by the courts
can you explain given
what we've been hearing before
about the court history of this
on
whether you agree with what's gone
before or what's in this letter
so i certainly agree with what's in the
letter i am not an attorney so that was
sent to by one of our legal counsel so
that it because it contains a legal
opinion so i cannot
speak further on that other than there
is a court case and it's the exact
opposite it had to do with
gas and cable and electric companies not
being taxed you know it but it's to the
effect that everyone has to be taxed
equitably and fairly so then we would
have to re-look at from my understanding
how we're taxing and assessing the
rights of way for other types of
users so gas companies for example would
follow-up you'll see
okay thank you
okay
uh any other questions seeing none thank
you very much thank you for the
opportunity
uh i just wanna dra
here
we weren't able to get anyone from the
uh municipal taxing division
okay but we we can we could try to we'll
talk afterwards thank you
so uh
is there anyone else who wants to
testify
okay uh can we take a look at the blue
sheet
you
thank you
okay
okay we're going to
open hearing on house bill 1450
including agricultural resources mr
chairman under the land in germany
heritage investment
before you go on you closed the hearing
on 1494 did you not yes not 1478. it was
just a misspoken
word okay i closed the hearing thank you
all right 14
14.94 thank you
i probably didn't have my
glasses on
and we opened up we opened the hearing
on 1450 hospital 1450 including
agricultural resources under the land
and community heritage investment
program
and the prime sponsor
is
rep
tony kaplan from merrimack six who
supports the bill obviously
thank you mr chair and uh members of the
at the outset i should say that this
this bill isn't intended to alter the
conservation program of the land and
community heritage program
so much as it is intended to formalize
agricultural resources
as a worthy statewide priority for
conservation
i want to recognize the invaluable work
that the atlanta community heritage
investment program already does
with farm conservation under its natural
resource rubric
by formalizing agriculture as a priority
area written into law
i don't foresee or intend to rethink the
organization's strategizing on the
choices it makes
which are based on well thought out
criteria and networking with a large
number of stakeholder organizations and
citizens across new hampshire
but what i do want to do is give
agricultural organizations and groups
that represent diverse farming interests
and local food interests a seat at the
table when prioritizing how best to
conserve the state's resources
in the background to this bill are the
demographic challenges facing new
hampshire farms where nearly one-third
of farmers are 65 or over and most of
these are farming without a younger
farmer alongside them ready to take over
operations or a plan for succession
this data suggests that the future of
farming in new hampshire may be facing
uncertainty that could hurt our state's
character and quality of life
and so it's important to take steps to
ensure that at the appropriate time
there is a way forward including
increased use of agricultural easements
for interested parties to ensure that
these properties remain as farms
why is it important to conserve farms i
think it goes beyond the scenic value of
having farms remain a part of the
landscape although that too is important
i believe it is a strategic goal for the
state to retain
as much food self-sufficiency as we can
for several reasons
we've seen what the covid pandemic has
done to supply chains and distribution
of goods across the country
having our food sourced from local farms
means less exposure to the disruptions
of supply and
uh
that may come with future climate change
events and god forbid an even worse
pandemic than the one we're currently
still in
also local food is healthy food by and
large and one of the hidden costs in our
society that again we're seeing play out
tragically in the pandemic is our over
reliance on industrially produced
highly processed foods coming from afar
sometimes very far that are the exact
opposite of local food produced on small
farms that are answerable
to a clientele of friends and neighbors
and fellow citizens
the u.s industrial food system although
producing an abundance of cheap
questionably nutritious food also leads
to epidemic levels of obesity and
chronic disease that makes our country
one of the unhealthiest in the world
tragically with a falling life
expectancy rate due in part to our junk
food diet
retaining our farm landscape as a
working landscape supplying products
to local as well as export markets is
the first step to ensure that new
hampshire citizens can rely on local
healthy food options now and in the
future
currently it's estimated that new
hampshire farms could support about six
percent of the state's population with
local food
one of the lowest percentages in new
england
it's imperative that we make efforts to
increase that level of food security as
a safeguard against future lean times as
well as the advantages of local food to
greater health
local farms retain dollars in local
economies that would otherwise flow out
of state
maintaining a base of viable productive
farms will greatly enhance new hampshire
and economic terms and in ways
that our current economic system fails
to measure such as greater health
environmental services such as carbon
sequestration along with the
already mentioned scenic value
local agriculture contributes
significantly to new hampshire's
economic output despite the challenges
facing the state's farmers new hampshire
has more than 4 thousand farms covering
470 000 acres
the state estimates agricultural
industries supports more than 20
thousand jobs with an economic value of
some 850 million dollars
this includes 479 million dollars in
direct sales of agricultural and other
horticultural products and services and
372 million in direct spending by
agricultural related tourism
increasing those numbers relies on many
factors but an essential component will
be increasing the ability of young and
beginning farmers to access agricultural
land and that will depend on retaining
our existing farms as productive parts
of the economy as the current generation
of farmers look to pass on their
holdings
market forces work against farm
retention and we see that becoming
especially true given recent hikes in
land speculation and spiking land prices
agricultural land values are increasing
at a seven percent year-to-year rate not
seen in over a decade according to the
u.s department of agriculture's 2021
land value summary report
new hampshire citizen sits at the high
end of variation across the country
given our northeastern location
all the more reason that there is an
additional funding mechanism attached to
this bill that would include increase
the l-chip's ability to fund a wide
array of projects going forward and help
meet the state's strategic conservation
needs in a fiscally responsible fashion
and with that i'll conclude my comments
and ask for your support for this bill
and i'm willing to take questions
thank you for your testimony
i have one question and maybe it's a
comment um i know in my town stratum i
can think of at least four farms
that we've put into conservation but the
town that was a town effort to put them
in conservation
we raised the money with the town and i
i'll let the elche people talk in a
minute
i i can't recall if we took a little up
chapman are you ready we did yes
so it seems like there's already a
mechanism
to try to preserve our our town's uh
land and heritage by preserving the
farms one of the bigger ones is this
doug skaman's farm
who was his former speaker of the house
that's in conservation most properties
in conservation
so
um well i i i guess
some of what you want to do is already
happening
um i don't know if you're aware of that
or not
yeah man as i mentioned in my testimony
the l chip already does do a lot of work
with agricultural easements there's no
no question about that
um uh my point is that that that uh
the desire for more of those projects
will only increase you know in the
coming years all right thank you
any other questions
representative raumi and then
representative laurie
thank you the l-chip letter that we've
already gotten now
says that 41 of all land conservation
projects funded by l-chip have included
farmland protection
which sounds to me like they could
easily use the extra money that you're
taking from the general and education
trust funds
on
for those purposes that they're already
doing
to use that
that extra money they could already
qualify for what
there isn't
but it looks like there would be
i'm not sure whether it's legal legally
required language or not but that uh
anything it that was not for a farm
would um
go back to the general fund if it wasn't
spent
that's correct
of this extra money yes
that's correct although the the money is
not intended strictly for farm
conservation the money raised by this
bill would go to all the strategic areas
of the lg i couldn't sorry i can't hear
you the money the money raised by the
wording of this bill is not intended
strictly for agricultural uses it's use
it's intended for the overall use of the
l-chip program
appropriation for
for l-chip in addition to the one that
they have had
thank you that helps quite a lot
um the other question was what is a farm
does it include the woodlots that i'm
not sure they count
as far as the strict definition of what
a farm is you know i really couldn't
answer that question i'm sure somebody
from the department of agriculture might
know the legal definition of a farm if
someone right behind you would know an
it would however if we were going to
hold it to that have to
tie to the definition of agriculture
that's i think which i think that
includes
uh tourism weddings
i mean i know that's a controversial
issue and there are there have been you
know bills recently
around what is
what constitutes a farm so you know
i think i think you can ask
commissioner jasper that question okay
okay well he's going to be next uh
representative ah thank you mr chair
i i noticed in the bill that it
indicates that uh uh you're an ad people
to the
commission that would include
representing local interests
but this would be a statewide commission
so how can they
represent local interest if they're
representing
the state
as would be the first part of the
question
and the second part of the question is
local planning boards
have to take into consideration current
use
when they were creating a subdivision
or they're creating an industrial area
depending upon
where the general land or the
agricultural land is being
uh converted
so it's aren't the
issues to which you just spoke already
being addressed
would be the second part
okay as far as local food interests
which is the wording of the bill
there are organizations that are working
on on increasing the supply of food
in the state as a whole from locally
sourced farms so when it says local food
it means it's a statewide
rubric and those organizations work all
across the state
that would be supported by this by
having a voice at the table of the
l-chip
as far as what planning boards
do in terms of zoning for agriculture
i'm not sure how the how this bill would
impact
at that level of
of the of the process
so
yes follow
i was referring to the fact that a
landowner
regardless of who it is has the right to
use his land profit from his land or
dispose of his land
would this not
kind of get in the way of that if
somebody
um say was the last member of a family
who wanted to do farming and
open the gate and let the cows go out
roaming across group 111.
yeah no i mean i i think that what this
would do would be offer more choices to
people in that position
um this is not a man it's not saying you
have to do this or you have to do that
it's just
for people who want to keep their farms
in farming and and and this would offer
them a way forward and make it easier to
what's that
yes uh representative
thank you um
i'm in greenland
and i think uh there's some property in
greenland that's benefiting
from this as well
it's going into
uh conservation now family will
hikers and 150 acres i believe
but the overarching
uh
the rule setting of this thing is has
been set up by the southeast land trust
so
like following up on
the question about how this proceeds
down the
down the road i believe that would you
would you agree that land is
set up for the next 100 years are in
perpetuity for
conservation because of its
it's a southeast land trust that's
really putting this uh together
am i speaking correctly about this or
well i'm not sure the details of that
arrangement but usually there are you
know there are different stakeholders
that get involved in these projects so
i'm not surprised that a land trust is
involved and sometimes it's
municipalities sometimes it's a
combination of that and they usually
look for some kind of funding
from something like the l-chip to to
complete the package
um
but yeah they're usually uh working 100
years down the road i mean it depends
but they're taking that land out of
development for a certain number of
years
you all said
uh none so thank you very much for your
testimony
uh speaking of uh former speakers of the
house sean jasper who's also
currently the
commissioner of agriculture who's
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee it's always a pleasure to be
back in
front of ways and means where i uh spent
more years than on any other uh
policy committee during my time in the
house and you survived then you survived
i did
you must have served with susan then i i
certainly did
and
she has the mic off it was probably good
i have a feeling
she said
um
at any rate
might surprise you i i am here in
opposition to this bill
i do believe that if it ain't broke we
shouldn't fix it
in this case i don't think that l-chip
is
is broken in this regard at all i do sit
on l-chip as a non-voting member
representing obviously agriculture
so
when i look at adding a person
representing agriculture i think about
well now we're probably going to open it
up to more areas wanting to be
represented and i don't think that's
that's healthy but if i consider
agriculture to be a natural resource
so i think it's already represented i'm
a little bit puzzled by representing
agricultural and local interests because
i don't know how you would define that
but i would point out that currently
there's already one member who shall
represent municipal interests that's a
low that's local interest
one representing local planning
interests that's a local interest
and one representing regional planning
commissions
and generally i would consider that to
be
local as well
but with the commissioner of agriculture
sitting even though it's a non-voting
position i think agriculture has been
well represented
over the years
i will tell you that during my four
years
sitting there
the voting members have listened very
carefully to what what i've had to say
and i
do not feel that by not having a vote
that that's really
had a negative impact
to the agricultural
interests at all
um in
this past year we were fortunate first
time in four years we actually had more
money than we had
applicants i don't see
the reason to take money away
from the many other needed areas in
state government to put it here i think
the balance has been struck pretty well
additionally
as you may or may not know
prior to l-chip existing
there was a program within the
department of agriculture to buy
specifically agricultural lands
that was not funded after l-chip
came into existence but in the last two
budgets
it has been funded covet is sort of
um not allowed me to get to where i'd
like to be at this at this point but it
is a
non-lapsing fund and we expect to get
that up and running and i and i think if
there was a need for
more money for agricultural lands
specifically that would be a better
place to put it because
it would be specific to
agriculture
as you just heard from the sponsor and i
do appreciate the fact that he has put
this
this bill in and his his thoughts in in
that area but i think if if we felt
there was a need for more money it
fund which allows us also to match
federal funds
and there are other matches out there
for l-chip and none of the l-chip pro
projects really are just stand-alone
with l-chip and i i think the system is
working very well
at this time um and i really
um while i am you know 100 percent
behind the mission of l-chip and applaud
what it does and i have to tell you that
you know agriculture has been
very very
well treated by the l-chip board in the
time that i've been there and i think
from the the information you have in the
letter from l-chip
it always has been
so i don't think there's a
any should be any concern that l-chip is
not being
fair to agricultural interests i'll be
glad to answer any questions well just
this just for the record again
your position is that
clearly there are agricultural projects
as well as other projects and
agriculture is not discriminated against
in any way not at all okay thank you
president
thank you mr chair thank you uh
commissioner for taking my question
again i just want to kind of summarize
what i think i heard from you which was
that between our current current use
laws
and our l-chip program
current use keeping spaces open and the
l-chip program buying conservation
easements that the green spaces and
farms in new hampshire are pretty well
protected and anybody wants some sort of
protection has roots available to them
there's no re need to expand this
program
i think that's
with the program that i've reinstituted
i think that's very true the federal
government has put a lot of money into
the farm bill and i can tell you that i
am not aware of any farm in the state of
new hampshire that has wanted to convert
their land into protected
lands that has not been able to and
which has gone out of business as a
result of
of that lack of funding so i do think we
found a good balance within the state of
new hampshire at this time thank you
commissioner
representative
[Laughter]
as you can see uh
mr commissioner we've come to the 21st
century with microphones now
we certainly have
any other questions
okay thank you very much for your time
if i could address what representative
omni
asked
um
forestry is part of agriculture within
the definition i think it's 21
a so
within our within the department's
farm
program
only
actual agricultural land has been
purchased to this point i'm not sure
that that would be um
something that you know we couldn't
purchase part of a farm with forestry
because i think under the definition and
it does allow it but it it clearly is
when you look at at the rsas
it is included so
thank you very much for your time thank
you no more questions correct okay
you're all set thank you
and our last pink card is paula
left the best for last
good afternoon thank you so much for
allowing me to speak i will be very
brief because commissioner jasper is an
outstanding spokesperson for elship as
it turns out um i do rather than
reviewing what you already have in front
of you i just want to highlight a few
points that came up in your earlier
discussion
um what this bill proposes to do is
increase our funding but it does limit
use of that increased funding which is
approximately 500 000 a year to only
acquisition projects l-chip also does
historic rehabilitation projects and
studies this bill would not allow us to
use
these new funds for that purpose
so it would um it's also a lapsing
funding source where our current funding
is non-lapsing so it would require some
minor administrative
adjustments on our part but i wouldn't
consider those insurmountable by any
means and the funding um the increased
funding would absolutely be welcome and
well used there are farms i can think of
one right now in milan that is not that
wishes to be conserved and can't be
those problems range from a lack of
available funding also easement holders
up in the north country is a problem so
there are a number of problems that
could be addressed that would increase
the pace of farmland conservation
funding is is one aspect of that lcp
will never turn away a new funding
source so i certainly do not want to go
on record saying we have enough funding
we have turned away approximately 500
projects in the life of the program and
about half of those are land
conservation thankfully only 13 have
been farms and of those there's only one
that i am aware of that was converted to
developed use so our record of farmland
protection is very very strong but that
does not mean there aren't farms that
aren't protected that could be
farmland conservation is one of the
hardest types of conservation to do
it is very complicated in terms of land
use it's very challenging for the farmer
to make the decision to put their land
in conservation and it's very
challenging for the organizations that
are taking on the easement so in
greenland yes that is a southeast land
trust project that's going to protect
farmland it's also going to protect you
know the great bay estuary it's also
going to protect drinking water supply
that's that's a fantastic project but
there are multiple stakeholders and it's
complicated
so there's a lot of work still to be
done a farm does include a woodlot often
and this is true when we work with our
federal funding partners if you think
about a historic farm you're going to
have a certain amount that is in crop
and then the farmer is also relying on
that wood lot and that continues to this
day so those um farmland does for us
include that
and i think um the only other thing i
would just clarify is 100 years we do
work in perpetuity um so we deal in
forever so the farms that we're
conserving as well as all of our
conservation land is protected forever
and with that i am happy to answer any
questions
okay any questions
nope seeing none thank you very much
you're very welcome thank you does does
anyone have a question on the fiscal
note we have the dra here
i think we're talking about five hundred
thousand ish
uh one quarter percent
would be five hundred thousand
um
that that would come out of
education and the general general fund
i think it's 33 percent
goes education and 67 goes to the
general fund
but if anybody needs clarity we have dra
here no okay
so
uh anyone else want to testify
saying none um
representative
genegan can you just grab the
okay so no one on the blue sheet i will
close the hearing on house bill 1450.
nothing tomorrow
no
right
let's start with tuesday start with
tuesday it talks with the caucus
hey good seeing you glad you're back
oh
you